OKAY GOOD GOOD AFTERNOON
EVERYONE WE'RE GOING TO GET
STARTED AS A- SUBCOMMITTEE.
WE'VE GOT- THE PRESENCE OF-
MEMBERS OF BOTH SIDES OF. THE
AISLE HERE SO BUT WE'LL GO TO
SOME HOUSEKEEPING FIRST AND
WILL- HAVE OUR FIRST PRESENTER-
COME BEFORE US SO THEREAFTER
GOOD AFTERNOON AND WELCOME I
WOULD LIKE TO CONVENE THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE CHILE'S.
ENERGY HEARING AS A SUB
COMMITTEE- SERGEANTS WILL
CONTINUE TO CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS BEFORE WE MOVED TO
GENDER HAVE A FEW HOUSEKEEPING
ANNOUNCEMENTS TO MAKE TODAY WE
HAVE TEN BILLS. ON THE AGENDA WE
WILL HAVE THE ASSUME ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IRWIN TEMPORARY FILLING
THE VACANCY ON OUR COMMITTEE
TODAY WELCOME ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
ONCE IS MAY BE IN PERSON OR USE
A MODERATED TELEPHONE SERVICE.
CALL NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING IS
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO.
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN IN THE
ACCESS CODE IS. ONE THREE ONE
FIVE FOUR THREE SEVEN. YOU CAN
ALSO FIND THIS NUMBER ON THE
ASSEMBLY TWO LADIES AND ENERGY
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AS WELL AS ON
THE TV SCREEN. IF YOU HAVE ANY
PROBLEMS WITH THE MODERATE PHONE
SERVICE YOU CAN CALL THE
COMMITTEE. NUMBER AS WELL NINE
ONE SIX THREE ONE NINE TWO ZERO
EIGHT THREE. AND A MEMBER OF OUR
TEAM WILL BE THERE TO ASSIST YOU
AGAIN WE HAVE TEN. MEASURES ON
TODAY'S AGENDA FIVE ARE IN THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. AS WE PROCEED
WITH THE WITNESSES A PUBLIC
COMMENT I WANT TO MAKE SURE
EVERYONE UNDERSTANDS THAT THE
ASSEMBLY HAS RULES. TO ENSURE WE
MAINTAIN ORDER AND RUN AN
EFFICIENT AND FAIR HEARING-
TESTIMONIES OMITTED TO FOUR
MINUTES TOTAL. TWO MINUTES
SUPPORT TWO MINUTES IN
OPPOSITION. FOR ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES ON THE MEASURE ONLY
STATE YOUR NAME POSITION. AND
AFFILIATION IF ANY. YOU KNOW YOU
SAW YESTERDAY WHAT HAPPENED IF
YOU DON'T FOLLOW THOSE RULES THE
CHAIR WILL LET YOU KNOW- YOU
BETTER FOLLOW THE RULES. WE WILL
LIMIT THE REMOTE PUBLIC COMMENT
PERIODS. OF THIS HEARING WHERE
WITNESSES ONLY STATE THEIR NAME
POSITION AND AFFILIATION I. MADE
THAT VERY CLEAR ALREADY. IF WE
EXCEED THIS TIME FOR THE MEASURE
YOU WERE CALLING IN FOR PLEASE
SUBMIT YOUR TESTIMONY. THROUGH
THE EMAIL ADDRESS ON OUR
WEBSITE. I WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM
DURING THE HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY. TO ALL- MEETINGS. AND
WELL WE DON'T HAVE A QUORUM WE
WILL START AS A SUBCOMMITTEE.
AND SO I'LL ASK OUR FIRST
PRESENTER. TO- COME FORWARD. AND
THAT'S IS A- ASSEMBLY BILL. AB
TWENTY TWO OH FOUR.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS AB TWENTY TWO OH FOUR
WOULD CREATE THE OFFICE OF THE
CLEAN ENERGY WORKFORCE WITHIN
THE LABOR AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AGENCY TO MONITOR
AND TRACK CARBON NEUTRAL
PROJECTS AS WELL AS CREATE A
ROBUST WORK FOR THE WORK FORCE
DEVELOPMENT STRATEGY TO SHIFT TO
A CARBON NEUTRAL ECONOMY AB
TWENTY TWO OH FOUR WILL ALSO
CREATE THE CLEAN ENERGY
WORKFORCE BOARD. THIS BILL IS
ABOUT GOOD GOVERNANCE
ACCOUNTABILITY TRANSPARENTLY AND
MOST IMPORTANTLY PEOPLE THERE
ARE MANY EFFORTS LOCALLY
REGIONALLY AND STATEWIDE TO
TRANSITION FROM FOSSIL FUELS TO
A CLEAN ENERGY FUTURE TO REACH
OUR AMBITIOUS GOALS WHETHER B.
SB ONE HUNDRED TARGET A 100%
CARBON NEUTRAL RENEWABLE ENERGY
BY TWENTY FORTY FIVE REDUCING
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS AND
RELATEDLY EXPANDING ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLE INFRASTRUCTURE
TO MOVE PEOPLE AND GOODS WITH
RENEWABLE ENERGY IT'S IMPERATIVE
THAT WE HAVE. THE STATE WENT OFF
AS THE HOLES ALL LEVELS OF
GOVERNMENT ACCOUNTABLE FOR THIS
TRANSITION AB TWENTY TWO OH FOUR
SIX ESTABLISHED OFFICE OF CLEAN
ENERGY WORKFORCE WHICH IN
COORDINATION WITH THE RELATIVE
STATE AGENCIES STICK. WITH THE
MODERATE. APPLE OFF CLEAN ENERGY
FUTURE. OFFICE AND AFFORDABLE
INSURE THAT TRANSPARENCY
ACCOUNTABILITY THAT WE LOCAL
PROJECTS ARE BEING BUILT. THE
WORK FORCE IS HERE AND THAT WE
WILL IN FACT BE ABLE TO REACH
OUR NATION'S PARTICLES. AS A
MOTHER I'M DEEPLY DEEPLY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE FUTURE OF
OUR PLANET. AND OUR CHILDREN AB
TWENTY TWO OH FOUR WHAT IS YOUR
THAT YOU CAN FIND GOALS. BETTER
THAN WE FOUND IT. THIS IS OUR
WHAT WE CALL IT TBH SPECIAL I
WROTE THIS BY MYSELF SO THERE
ARE NO WITNESSES TODAY. SO IF
YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS HAPPY TO.
HAPPY TO ANSWER THEM I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I'VE
UP. THANK THANK YOU WE DON'T
HAVE A AS YOU SAID ANY
WITNESSES- I'LL ASK THE- MEMBERS
OF- THIS AUDIENCE IF THERE'S
ANYONE WISHING. TO SPEAK IN
FAVOR. OF THE BILL. CÁC NO ONE
WILL THE MOM- TO SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE CALLING IN IN IN SUPPORT
. OF YOUR MEASURE. THANK YOU MR
AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY TWO BEFORE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY TWO OH FOUR
YOU MAY PRESS ONE. AND THEN ZERO. WE HAVE NO COMMENTS IN THE
QUEUE AT THIS TIME OKAY THANK
YOU- ASSUMING NO ONE CAME
FORWARD. TO SPEAK IN FAVOR AS
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION HERE IN THE
ROOM. ALL RIGHT TO NO ONE NO ONE
ON THE PHONE LINES. AT THIS
DOES- HAVE A DO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS- RECOMMENDATION
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. MAYBE I SHOULD ASK SOME OF
OUR COLLEAGUES IF THEY HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OF. THE AUTHOR. THAT
MUCH NO QUESTION MISTER CHARLES
IS GONNA TELL YOU THAT- TELL THE
AUTHOR- IT'S GOOD WORK THANKS
FOR MEETING WITH ME- I THINK
THIS IS THE SORT OF THINGS WE
NOT DOING AS WE TRANSITION FROM.
WHERE WE'VE BEEN TO WORLD WHERE
WE'RE GOING SO WHEN THE TIME
COMES UP THE LEAST OUT OF THE
CORNER OF THE MAKE IN MOTION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU. WE DO HAVE ANOTHER
AUTHOR MR MCCARTY. AB TWENTY
SEVEN HUNDRED. THANK YOU MR
GARCIA YES IS MY EIGHTH YEAR IN
THE ASSEMBLY CAME IN HERE WITH
YOU AND I'VE NEVER BEEN TO THIS
COMMITTEE WELCOME WELL FIRST
TIME YEAH SO ANYWAY I THINK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY PRESENT MY ON- HAVING AGREED READY TO
SUPPORT THE AUTOMOBILES OF THE
FUTURE AND AS WE KNOW WE HAVE A
LOT OF WORK TO DO TACKLING
CLIMATE CHANGE ME BEING A LEADER
IN THIS FRONT. AS WELL AS
ADDRESSING AIR QUALITY AND
EMISSIONS- AND A BIG PIECE OF
THIS MAKING SURE THAT OUR GREAT
IS READY- AS WE TRANSITION OUR
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR WHICH AS
WE KNOW THE TRACK AS THE PRIMARY
DRIVER POLLUTION GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS- WITH THIS- THIS BILL
IS ESSENTIALLY. AN EFFORT TO
REQUIRE- CARB TO SHARE THEIR
ELECTRIC FLEET DATA WITH THE
STATE'S UTILITIES SO THEY CAN
BETTER ANTICIPATE ELECTRICITY
GRID DEMANDS AND- MAKING SURE
THAT WE HAVE ENOUGH ELECTRICITY
AND ENERGY READY TO MEET THE-
THE GOALS OF OUR STATE AS WELL
AS THE CONSUMER DEMANDS OF THE
PEOPL OF CALIFORNIA I THANK YOU
FOR WORKING WITH US ON THIS BILL
AND YES I WILL BE TAKING THE
PROPOSED COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS.
AND WITH ME TO TESTIFY ARE
REPRESENTED OUR REPRESENTATIVES
FROM THE IN OUR DC AS WELL AS
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA EDISON THANK
YOU. PLEASE COME FORWARD.
I WOULD LIKE TO HAVE AN ARTISTIC
OFFERS ME HAPPY TO. HELLO GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR ADAM SMITH
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA EDISON
SCHERING ARE STRONG SUPPORT FOR
A BI TWENTY SEVEN HUNDRED. AS
YOU WELL KNOW THE TRANSPORTATION
SECTOR REMAINS THE PRIMARY
OBSTACLE TO REDUCING GHG
EMISSIONS IMPROVING OUR AIR
QUALITY AND TO COMBAT THIS
LEGISLATURE HAS RIGHTLY PUT FOR
THIS HISTORIC FUNDING PACKAGES
TO ENCOURAGE ELECTRIC VEHICLE
ADOPTION. MY DUTY CARS TO HAVE
DUTY TRUCKS THIS LEADERSHIP FROM
THE STATE IS HAVING REAL RESULTS
AS THE PORTS WAREHOUSES AND
OTHER BUSINESSES INCREASINGLY
SOCIAL ACTED VEHICLES WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE GREATEST
READY FOR THEM. THE LANGUAGE OF
THIS BILL PUTS THE PROBLEM
PERFECTLY FOR GOING TO MEET THE
GOAL OF A 100% OF ALL MEDIUM AND
HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES SOLD BY
TWENTY FORTY FIVE AND ENSURE
THAT THEIR NEEDS ZERO EMISSION
AND ALSO MEET THE MANY
REGULATORY DEADLINE SET UP BY
THE AIR RESOURCES BOARD AND
OTHER STATE AGENCIES. WE NEED TO
ADVANCE ZERO MISSION STRUCTURE
AB TWENTY SEVEN HUNDRED DOES
JUST THAT IT WOULD ENSURE
VEHICLE CORPORATIONS CAN MEET
CRITICAL GRID INFRASTRUCTURE
NEEDS IN ANTICIPATION. OF
INCREASED VEHICLE
ELECTRIFICATION. AB TWENTY SEVEN
HER GETS UTILITIES WHAT WE NEED
TO PLAN APPROPRIATELY AND THEN
DIRECTS US TO TAKE ACTION. THE
BILL WOULD PROVIDE UTILITIES
WITH ANNUAL FLEET DATA ALLOWING
US TO FORECAST AND ANTICIPATE
FUTURE ELECTRIFICATION EXPANSION
WITH MUCH GREATER CONFIDENCE.
THIS DATA WILL INFORM PLANS THE
INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES WOULD
TAKE TO THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION FOR APPROVAL. AND
ONCE APPROVED WE GO GET TO WORK
WE THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THIS GOOD IDEA FORWARD WE
SUPPORT IT. AS AN IMPLEMENTING
UTILITY WE URGE THE MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE SUPPORTED TODAY
AS WELL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
WE'RE GONNA ASK A MODERATOR TO
PLEASE UP THANK YOU IN THE NEXT
AT. BAT PRESENTER. GENERATE CAN
YOU GIVE ME. WE CAN HEAR YOU. MY
NAME IS MY LAWLER CRIME IN CLEAN
ENERGY ATTORNEY AT THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL AND
I'M PLEASED TO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TODAY TO CUT THE PIE
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY SEVEN
HUNDRED. AB TWENTY SEVEN HUNDRED
IS A CRITICAL MEASURE FOR
KEEPING CALIFORNIA CONTRACT.
QUALITY CLIMATE GOALS BY
ENSURING THE ELECTRICAL GRID IS
PREPARED FOR THE COURT
TRANSPORTATION PUBLICATION.
CALIFORNIA HAS AMBITIOUS GOALS
IN REGULATION FOR ELECTRIFYING
THE TRANSPORTATION SECTOR
INCLUDING THE GOVERNOR GOALS OF
HAVING 1100% OF NEW CAR SALES
YOUR MISSION BY TWENTY THIRTY
FIVE. TO MEET THIS GOAL. YOU
HAVE TO MAKE A CALIFORNIA WILL
NEED ROUGHLY ONE POINT TWO
MILLION CHARGERS AND EIGHT
MILLION EV'S ALRIGHT BY TWENTY
THIRTY. HOW IN THE CURRENT
INJECTED APPROACH FOR BUILDING
IT UP AND- INTEGRATING LAW. LOTS
LOAD. QUICKLY WAS IN A DELAY.
AND ULTIMATELY LARGER CALL THAT
WILL MAKE IT THE THREE REQUIRE.
IN TRANSPORTATION THAT BY
EXECUTIVE. INTEGRITY LIKE THE
EVENT CLEAN TRUCKS AND
EVENTUALLY WE WILL. IN ORDER TO
PREPARE THE GROUND TO ADEQUATELY
SERVE ALTERNATIVE AKHTER CARD
WHICH OX COMING OVER THE NEXT
DECADE WE NEED A MORE PROACTIVE
APPROACH AGREED PLANNING SERVING
A CUSTOMER. AB TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED ONE MAY DESPITE. FOR
TRICKY PLANNING. SO WE HAVE THE
GROUP WE NEED WHEN WE NEED IT.
TO COME A WIDESPREAD
TRANSPORTATION ELECTRIFICATION
TO ME THE STATE CLIMATE AIR
QUALITY IN EQUITY GOLD. AND
RELATED REGULATIONS. THIS IS
ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT FOR
SUPPORTING YOUR EDUCATIONAL
MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY VEHICLE.
WHICH WILL PROVIDE MUCH NEEDED
ONLY SHOWING ME TO LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES AND COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR DOCUMENT NEAR FREEWAYS
PORTS RAILYARDS. AND OTHER
FACILITIES THAT GENERATE
SIGNIFICANT LEVELS OF AND
GETTING OFF. PUT MORE FOR YOU
DEFINES MAY BE ELECTRIFICATION
OF THE TRACK BACK TO BECOME
ACTIVE. SO THEY PROGRESS TOWARDS
GOAL. AND NOT QUITE BEEN ALL GOT
. INSTALLING LOT OF GRID NEEDED
TO TRY LECTURE CARS BOATS. WILL
NOT ONLY THAT THEY NEED QUITE
ACCORDING I AGREE GOAL. BUT ALSO
TELL YOU AND- ALSO XCELERATED
CHECK OCCUPATION THE PUT DOWN
PRESSURE ON- THE BENEFIT OF ALL
THE COMPANY. BUT WE APPRECIATE.
MIKE LEADERSHIP IN OFFERING THE
PROMISE BECAUSE- AND- URGE
HIDEOUT THANK YOU. THANK YOU- SO
WE DON'T HAVE ANYONE. TO SPEAK
OPPOSITION- BUT- WE WILL ALLOW
IF THERE'S A WHO WANTS FORWARD
AND- DO SO AT THIS TIME AND THEN
WE'LL OPEN IT UP FOR PUBLIC
COMMENTS HERE. IN THE ROOM AND A
TO THE MODERATE PLEASE. THANK
YOU MR. AUTHOR PATRICK WELCH
WITH THE CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL
UTILITIES SENSATION. I
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED AT CBA IS COORDINATING
WITH THE STATE ON ITS CLEAN
ENERGY GOALS AND SEE MAYES
MEMBERS ARE CLOSELY WORKING WITH
THE COMMUNITIES AND LOCAL
LEADERSHIP. TO MEET STATE AND
LOCAL CLEAN ENERGY REQUIREMENTS.
AT THE SAME TIME USED FOR
SUPPORTING EFFORTS TO
DECARBONIZE THE TRANSPORTATION
SECTOR THROUGH FACILITATING EASY
CHARGERS PROVIDING EVEY REBATES.
AND MAKE APPROPRIATE SYSTEM
UPGRADE IS NEEDED. WE APPRECIATE
THE MEMBERS THAT ARE BEING
ACCEPTED TODAY BY THE AUTHOR AND
THINK THEY MOVE THE BILL IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION. WE'RE STILL
REVIEWING THE LANGUAGE
ADDITIONAL CLARIFICATIONS MAY BE
NEEDED. AND I WANT TO NOTE ONE
IMPORTANT THING FOR THE MEMBERS
OF THIS COMMITTEE ON THIS ISSUE.
THERE ARE CURRENT SIGNIFICANT
SUPPLY CONSTRAINTS CONSTRAINTS
THAT ARE MAKING THE INSTALLATION
OF BOTH EVEY INFRASTRUCTURE
ELECTRICAL INFRASTRUCTURE VERY
DIFFICULT RIGHT NOW. YOU TO TAKE
THREE TO FOUR MONTHS TO GET A
TRANSFORMER FROM TIME OF ORDER.
IT NOW TAKES TWO TO THREE YEARS.
AT A GENERAL COST INCREASE OF
SIXTY PERCENT. THE SUPPLY CHAIN
ISSUES ARE IMPACTING ALMOST ALL
PARTS OF ELECTRICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE RIGHT NOW SO WE
REALLY APPRECIATE THAT THE
<c.magenta>ANGUAGE OF TIMELY UPGRADE IS</c>
COMING OUT THE BILL BECAUSE THAT
WOULD HAVE REALLY COMPLICATED
THINGS UNDER THE CURRENT.
SITUATION DOING CLOSING SEEM A
PROCEEDS WORKING WITH AUTHOR
ERNEST AFTER DRESS OR CONCERNS
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO ADDRESS A RIPPLING
WHICH THANK YOU THANK YOU REMAIN
OPEN UP TO A PUBLIC COMMENTS.
FOR THOSE HERE IN THE ROOM YOU
CAN SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION PLEASE STATE YOUR
NAME ORGANIZATION. AND YOUR
POSITION. THIS CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
WHICH BEHALF THE- COASTAL IF YOU
TO. AND REVERSING. NEARLY ALL
THE EMPLOYEES OF THE BILL ALL
THE MUNICIPAL AND INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITIES AND THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF ELECTRICAL
WORKERS THINK THIS IS A GREAT
BILL. IN FULL SUPPORT THANK YOU
. MISTER TURN MEMBER SYLVIA SO
LISA SHAW ON BEHALF OF ADVANCED
ENERGY ECONOMY AND STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
ANYONE ELSE. IT WILL GO TO THE-
PHONE LINES FOUR LINES ARE OPEN
MR A MODERATOR. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF AB
TWENTY SEVEN HUNDRED YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
OF AB TWENTY SEVEN HUNDRED YOU
MAY PRESS ONE. AND THEN ZERO.
THERE ARE NO COMMENTS IN QUEUE
FOR AB TWENTY SEVEN HUNDRED OKAY
THANK YOU. HELLO BRING BACK TO
THE MEMBERS OF MANY QUESTIONS
AND COMMENTS. OKAY WE STILL ARE
LACKING A QUORUM TO. TAKE ANY
ACTION WAS RECORDED BUT WOULD
LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK YOU JUST-
FREESHEET YOU'RE WORKING- WITH
THAT SAID. YOU KNOW OUR OUR
CLIMATE GOALS ARE ARE NOT USING
CALIFORNIA AND WE KNOW THAT WE
HAVE A GOAL TO GET TWO. 100%
CLEAN CARS NEXT COUPLE DECADES
IT'S NOT GONNA JUST HAPPEN
OVERNIGHT WITH THE SNAP OF A
FINGER SO WE NEED- SOME PLANNING
IT'S A WORK SO THIS IS WHAT THIS
BILL ENTAILS AND- RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR THE BILL TO THE
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. WE HAVE- WE HAVE A
QUORUM. WE HAVE A QUORUM. FOMIN
ASKED THE- SECRETARY TO HANDLE
THESE- FISSIONING THIS THE
MEETING TO ORDER. EDUARDO GARCIA
HI PRESENT AND WATER GARCIA HERE
PATTERSON PATTERSON HERE THERE
CAN CARILLO CARRILLO HERE CHEN
CHEN HERE CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM
HERE CRISTINA GARCIA HOLDEN
IRWIN. IRWIN HERE MAYES MAYES
HERE MURATSUCHI MURATSUCHI HERE
CORK REYES SANTIAGO KING THAT'S
EIGHT ALL RIGHT THANK YOU MAY I
ASK THAT WE START TOP AND AS FOR
A MOTION TO APPROVE THE TWENTY
SECOND AT FIVE I DON'T. THE
MOTION AND SECOND. TO ITEM FOUR
EIGHT NINE TEN EXACTECH. I
REMEMBER TO AB TWENTY TWO EIGHTY
THREE ITEM NUMBER NINE AB TWENTY
EIGHT FIFTY ONE ITEM NUMBER TEN
AB TWENTY NINE TWENTY NINE. DO
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS. I AM
NUMBER FOUR TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY
FOUR ITEM NUMBER EIGHT. AB
TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY FIVE DO
PASSED AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. EDUARDO GARCIA
EDUARDO GARCIA I PATTERSON
PATTERSON I'D BARRICADE HAND
CARILLO. CARILLO AYE CHAN AYE
CHAN AYE CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM
I CRISTINA GARCIA HOLDEN IRWIN-
WHEN I MAYES. MAYES AYE AMHERST
TEACHING MERCY GI QUIRK REYES
SANTIAGO TAKING PRINTS ZERO
THANK YOU WILL BE THE ROLE OPEN
FOR THE MEMBERS AT ON A LETTER
TO THE MOTION FOR A PARTY FILLED. TWENTY SEVEN HUNDRED. THE
MOTION SECOND. LOCAL I AM NUMBER
ONE A. B. THE CARD NUMBER. THREE
SEVEN HUNDRED. AB TWENTY SEVEN
HUNDRED THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED
WITH THE AUTHORS AGREEMENT TO
TAKE AMENDMENTS AND
TRANSPORTATION. EDUARDO GARCIA
HI EDUARDO GARCIA I PATTERSON.
PATTERSON NOT VOTING. BARRICADE
HAND CARILLO CARILLO AYE CHAN.
CHEN NOT VOTING CUNNINGHAM
CUNNINGHAM I CRISTINA GARCIA
STANA GARCIA HI HOLDEN- WENT-
WHEN I MAYES. MAYES AYMER CG
MERCY GI QUIRK REYES SANTIAGO
KING. BUT SEVEN WILL BE THE ROLE
OPEN FOR OTHER MEMBERS AT ON ALL
ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO MOVE A. B.
TWENTY TWO- FOR THE MOTION TO
MISTER MAYES. YOUR SECOND. TAKE
HIM OF HIS CAREER. AB TWENTY TWO
OH FOUR. THE MOTION IS DUE PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS EDUARDO GARCIA
HI EDUARDO GARCIA I PATTERSON.
PATTERSON NO BETTER CAN CARILLO
CARRILLO AYE CHAN. CHEN I
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM I.
CRISTINA GARCIA CRISTINA GARCIA
HI HOLDEN. IRWIN WHEN I MAYES
MAYES I MURATSUCHI RESEARCHING
NOT VOTING CORK. I REYES REYES I
SANTIAGO TAKING. THAT'S NINE ONE
THANK YOU WILL LEAVE THE ROLE
OPEN FOR OTHER MEMBERS HAD ON
AND WILL ASK- SUMMER WICKS.
HELLO STARTER PRESENTATION ON A
B. TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY NINE. THE
WEST COAST OF. WHAT. OKAY SPOKE.
WITH HIM HE SAID OKAY. COULD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
I'D LIKE TO BEGIN BY ACCEPTING-
THE COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS AND
THANK THE CHAIR AND THE DILIGENT
HARD WORKING COMMITTEE STAFF
WITH WORKING WITH MY OFFICE TO
CLARIFY THE GOALS THE BILL.
CLIMATE CHANGE IS AND WILL
CONTINUE TO INCREASE INCREASE
THE LIKELIHOOD AND SEVERITY OF
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES IN
CALIFORNIA. MORE THAN ONE
QUARTER OF THE STATE INCLUDING
MORE THAN HALF OF SOME UTILITY
SERVICE TERRITORIES. ARE NOW
CLASSIFIED AS A HIGH. FIRE
THREAT DISTRICT. RECOGNITION OF
THIS IS WHY I WAS PLEASED TO SEE
THAT MY DISTRICTS LOCAL UTILITY
P. GENIES ANNOUNCEMENT LAST YEAR
THAT THEY WERE PLANNING TO
CONDUCT A MULTI YEAR PROGRAM TO
UNDERGROUND APPROXIMATE TEN
THOUSAND MILES. OF OVERHEAD
DISTRIBUTION POWER LINES IN THE
HIGHEST WILDFIRE RISK AREAS BY
THE END OF THE DECADE. I'VE SEEN
THE POTENTIAL SAFETY IMPACTS OF
UNDERGROUNDING IN MY DISTRICT
WERE POWER LINES WERE BURIED.
FOLLOWING THE DEVASTATING
OAKLAND HILLS FIRE THAT MY
CONSTITUENTS EXPERIENCE. AND
BELIEVE THAT IS IN THE BEST LONG
TERM SOLUTION REDUCING THE RISK
OF IT- IGNITION IN CERTAIN AREAS
LIKE MINE. UNDER CURRENT LAW
HOWEVER UTILITIES CAN ONLY SEEK
PIECEMEAL INCREMENTAL REGULATORY
APPROVAL AS PART OF THEIR THREE
YEAR WILDFIRE MITIGATION PLAN
FOR AND PERIODIC GENERAL RATE
CASE APPLICATIONS. BOTH EXISTING
PROCESSES COVER ONLY RELATIVELY
SHORT PERIODS OF TIME AND DO NOT
PROVIDE THE LONG TERM RISK
ASSESSMENT NOR THE CERTAINTY
NEEDED FOR PLANNING AND
EXECUTION. OF PROGRAMS AS LARGE
AS UNDERGROUNDING AT SCALE. AB
TWO EIGHT EIGHT NINE WOULD HELP
ADDRESS THE ISSUE BY REQUIRING
THE OFFICE OF ENERGY
INFRASTRUCTURE SAFETY TO REVIEW
AND COMPARE LONG TERM UNDERGOING
PLANS WITHIN THE CONTEXT OF A
WILD WILDFIRE MITIGATION
PROGRAMS ON AN EXPEDITED BASIS.
IF APPROVED AS THEIR RISK
REDUCTION PROGRAM THE BILL WOULD
ALLOW. THE PLANS TO STAY IN
EFFECT FOR THE DURATION OF THE
COVERED PERIOD BETWEEN SEVEN AND
TEN YEARS. WITH ME TODAY ARE
REPRESENTATIVES FROM. A P.
JEANNIE AND THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION OF UTILITY EMPLOYEES
TO SPEAK FURTHER ALRP THEMSELF
INTRODUCE THANK YOU FOR MEMOREX.
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS CHRIS PATTERSON- ON
BEHALF OF P. G. TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. I WANTED TO
HAND IT OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE-
CHIEF WHO IS THE CHIEF SAFETY
OFFICER AND RISK OFFICER PG&E.
WHO CAN PROVIDE A LITTLE MORE
CONTEXT I'M INTO THE GENESIS OF
THIS BILL- AND REALLY DISCUSS.
WHY WE ARE LOOKING FOR A LONGER
TERM REGULATORY FRAMEWORK WITH
RESPECT TO OUR WILDFIRE
MITIGATION PROGRAM AND
SPECIFICALLY UNDERGROUNDING SO.
WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO INTRODUCE
ME TO SING. THANK YOU. A
RESPECTED CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I SINCERELY APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY- THAT YOU'VE
GIVEN MYSELF AND P. JEANNIE TO
MAKE A FEW REMARKS ABOUT THE
BILL. IN THE CONTEXT OF OUR
COMMITMENT. TO UNDERGROUND THE
HIGHEST RISK DISRIBUTION POWER
LINES IN OUR SERVICE AREA. THE
ONGOING DROUGHT THE HIGHER
TEMPERATURE INCREASED PLANS HAVE
SIGNIFICANTLY IT IS THE RISK OF
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES. AND
SINCE THE BEGINNING OF THE
TWENTY FIRST CENTURY NEARLY
THREE OUT OF FOUR YEARS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAVE BEEN
DROUGHT YEARS. NOW AS I REFLECT
ON. OUR SERVICE AREA ITSELF.
BACK IN TWENTY TWELVE THERE WAS
AN ASSESSMENT THAT WAS DONE TO
IDENTIFY. HIGH FIRE RISK AREAS.
FOR SERBIA AND WE HAVE. LESS
THAN 15% THAT DOESN'T. I FOR
RISKIER WOULD THROUGH THE
DROUGHT CAN OF TWENTY TO TWENTY
SIXTEEN. THAT SAME DOLLARS WAS
DOT EIGHT. MORE THAN. WHICH FIVE
ZERO IS IN A FIRE AREAS NEARLY
TRIP. IN LESS THAN HALF A DECADE
. NOT ONLY HAVE A WORSE IMPACT
ON THE MARTEL OF TREE BUT THEY-
YET THE FUEL FOR THE
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRE SPREAD-
AND THE IMPACT OF ALL FAR AS WE
ALL KNOW- BECAUSE WE FACED THEM
OURSELVES OUR FRIENDS FAMILIES
NEIGHBORS. HAVE EXPERIENCED THIS
FIRST HAND DEVASTATION THAT
COMES WITH NOT JUST AN IMMEDIATE
THREAT TO HUMAN LIFE AND
PROPERTY. NEGATIVE IMPACT ON THE
VALUE OF LIFE THE NATIONAL
RESOURCE FOR THE LOCAL ECONOMIES
ACROSS THE STATE. WERE
RESPONDING TO THIS CHALLENGE AND
MAKING EVERY EFFORT TO MITIGATE
RISK WITH THE MULTI FACETED
WILDFIRE SAFETY PROGRAM AND ONE
COMPONENT OF THAT IS
UNDERGROUNDING. AND LAST YEAR WE
HAD ANNOUNCED A MULTI YEAR
PROGRAM UNDERGROUND TEN THOUSAND
MILES OVER HIGHEST RECLINES IN
HIGH FIRE RISK AREAS IN THE TEN
THOUSAND IS OUT OF THE TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED.
VERSUS SERVICE AREA AND WHAT THE
STANDS THAT WE'VE TAKEN AS A
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRE SHE'LL
STOP AND WE WILL NOT REST. UNTIL
THAT BECOMES A REALITY OUR NEW
UNDERGROUNDING FOCUS AND
REPRESENTS THE LARGEST SUCH
EFFORT IN THE UNITED STATES TO
UNDERGROUND POWER LINES OF THE
WILDFIRE RISK REDUCTION MEASURE.
WE BELIEVE THAT UNDERGROUNDING
DISTRIBUTION POWER LINES IS THE
BEST LONG TERM SOLUTION FOR
KEEPING CUSTOMERS COMMUNITIES
AND OUR STATE SAFE. NOT ONLY DO
WE GET THE GREATEST OF THE RISK
REDUCTION NEARLY 99% OR MORE OR
FROM CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES THAT
COULD BE STARTED FROM YOU THE
EQUIPMENT. BUT WE ALSO GET
ADDITIONAL BENEFITS IN TERMS OF
IMPROVING CUSTOMER EXPERIENCE
AND REDUCING THE SAFETY RISK
WHEN WE DO HAVE TO DE ENERGIZE
THE RESULT PUBLIC SAFETY
PROPORTIONAL PROBE I'M- FOR THE
- POWER LINES SETTING. MS WILL
ALSO HAVE AN IMPACT COST.
BUSINESS THIS. ALL WE GET THE
OPPORTUNITY TO REAL. BUT THEN
NUMBER AN EX ARE NOW THE NORM
BEFORE OF ON FOR TWENTY ONE WE
WENT FROM DROP CONDITIONS THE
EARLY OF THE YEAR TO DECEMBER OF
LAST YEAR IT WILL BE EXPERIENCED
THE THIRD SNOWIEST MONTH ON
RECORD. DATING BACK TO NINETEEN
UNDERSTANDING PROVIDE. FROM
ADVERSELY IMPACTING OUR
CUSTOMERS DURING THOSE EXTREME
WEATHER CONDITIONS AS WELL. AND
THE LAST PIECE OF TOUCH ON IN
TERMS OF BENEFIT IS THAT WE ALSO
HAVE THE ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO
REDUCE COSTS ON AN ONGOING BASIS
BECAUSE UNDERGROUND THE ONE TIME
INVESTMENT. AND ONCE THE LINE IS
UNDERGROUND WE WILL USE THE ANY
SPENT ON ONGOING MAINTENANCE AND
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT WORK. ABLE
TO SPREAD THE COST OF WORK OVER
USEFUL LIFE. THE INFRASTRUCTURE
SPREADING THE COST OVER MULTIPLE
YEARS AND REDUCING THE UP FRONT
COSTS FOR CUSTOMERS. ANOTHER
BAND SOME QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
COST OF THIS PROGRAM AND WE ARE
CONFIDENT THAT WE CAN ACHIEVE
EFFICIENCIES AND ECONOMIES OF
SCALE THAT WOULD BRING DOWN
COSTS OVER THE LONG TERM. WE'VE
HAD TREMENDOUS EXAMPLES FROM
WORK THAT WE'RE DOING IN
PARADISE FOR THE BUTTE COUNTY
REBUILD. BECAUSE OF CONTINUE TO
COME DOWN AND UNDERGROUNDING HAS
MINIMIZED THE CUSTOMER IMPACT
FROM PS PSP PSS AND- A WINTER
STORMS. AND CLOSING OUR WILDFIRE
SAFETY AND UNDERGROUNDING
EFFORTS ARE MAKING A SYSTEM
SAFER AND MORE RESILIENT. TO THE
STATE'S EVER EVOLVING CLIMATE
CHANGES AND CHALLENGES
MITIGATING NOT JUST TODAY'S.
CLIMATE RISK BUT ALSO
TOMORROW'S. AND WILL BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE MORE RELIABLE SERVICE TO
OUR CUSTOMERS. AN AWFUL BETTER
SERVE CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU FOR
THE OPTION TO PROVIDE COMMENTS.
THANK YOU. MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBER SCOTT WHICH IN BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA COALITION OF
UTILITY EMPLOYEES. REPRESENTING
THE LINE MEN AND WOMEN WHO ARE
PERFORMING THIS EXTREMELY VITAL
AND DANGEROUS WORK. SIMPLY PUT
WHEN WE- SPENT SO MANY HOURS
WORKING IN THE CONFERENCE
COMMITTEE TO DEVELOP SB NINETY
ONE DIED AND THEN THE FOLLOWING
YEAR- WITH. REMEMBER HOLE. AB
FIFTY FOUR OR DEVELOP THE WHOLE
SORT OF PROCESS FOR FIRE
MITIGATION. UP YOU SIMPLY DO NOT
. IN VISION- UNDERGROUNDING
BEING AS A PREEMINENT A STRATEGY
AS IT HAS BECOME OUT OF
NECESSITY- THE CLIMATE CHANGES
THAT WE'VE WE'VE EXPERIENCED.
HAS CHANGE SO RAPIDLY THAT YOU
KNOW I THINK IF THERE'S BROAD
CONSENSUS THAT UNDERGROUNDING IS
ABSOLUTELY THE BEST APPROACH TO
PARTNER SYSTEMS UNFORTUNATELY
THAT TAKES A CREAM CREDIBLE
AMOUNT OF PLANNING- THE WORK
FORCE ISSUES ARE CONSIDERABLE I
MEAN WE'RE PULLING LINE MEN AND
WOMEN AND CONTRACTORS FROM ALL
OVER THE UNITED STATES NOT EVEN
THE WESTERN UNITED STATES THIS
IF YOU LOOK AT IT ALL OF THIS
WORK. IS IN COMPARISON TO OTHER
LARGE INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS
ROUND IT STAYS IT WILL BE IN THE
TOP THREE AS THE BIGGEST
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS BEING
UNDERTAKEN THAT TAKES A LOT OF
PLANNING. WATCHING THE CURRENT
PROCESS DOESN'T LEND ITSELF TO
THAT AND WE'RE TRYING TO
SYNERGIZE. THAT TYPE OF PLAN IT
COULD COME THROUGH THE GENERATE
CASES WITH- THE- FIRE MITIGATION
PLANS. TO MAKE THEM WORK MORE
COHESIVELY TOGETHER AND SO WE
WOULD TO ORIGINAL VOTE. THANK
THANK YOU- WE'RE GOING TO ASK TO
SEE IF- ANYONE IT'S GOING TO BE
TEN. IN A TO. IS NO ONE. AT
ANYONE IN THE ROOM HERE WISHING
TO SPEAK IN FAVOR. OF THE
MEASURE OR AGAINST PLEASE STATE
YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION IN YOUR
POSITION. HELLO BLOOD WITH THE
SILICON VALLEY LEADERSHIP GROUP
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. SEE NO
ONE ELSE CAN AFFORD MST
MODERATOR OFFICIAL OPEN UP THE
LINES. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY EIGHT
EIGHTY NINE. YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WHAT
YOU GET IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF AB
TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY NINE. YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
NINE FORTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS- KEVIN
JOHNSON OKAY AFTER THE
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
FEDERATION WE APPRECIATE THE
BILL ANALYSIS AND BELIEVE IT
HIGHLIGHTS MAC OF SOME OF THE
CONCERNS RAISED IN OPPOSITION
EITHER AND SO WE REMAIN
CONCERNED THAT WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO REVIEW THE ACTUAL
LANGUAGE OF THE AMENDMENT.
ADMITTED TO WERE WITH THE AUTHOR
SPONSOR. TO TRYING GET TO SHOW
WHERE WE FEEL LIKE. ARE ADEQUATE
PROTECT PROTECTED THANK YOU.
NINE FORTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. FIVE MY
NAMES CONOR STERN WITH IBEW
LOCAL TWELVE FORTY FIVE IN
STRONG SUPPORT. YEAH NO FURTHER
LINES IN Q. FOUR AB TWENTY EIGHT
EIGHTY NINE. SO MANY QUESTIONS.
I WOULD LIKE TO GET TO A PLACE
WHERE I COULD SUPPORT THIS BILL
- BUT I CAN'T AS OF TODAY.
BECAUSE OF THE CONCERNS RAISED
BY THE FARM BUREAU- I REPRESENT
A VERY LARGE. AREA OF
AGRICULTURE AND THEY BELIEVE
THAT THEY ARE IN THE CROSSHAIRS
. OF THESE KIND OF RATE
INCREASES AND THEY ARE CONCERNED
AND SO THEY THEY HAVE ISSUE
THESE GOT KINDS OF CONCERNS- AND
SO I'M GONNA JUST ABSTAINED. R.
UNTIL FARM BUREAU MAKES A
DECISION THAT MAKES IT VERY
CLEAR I HAVE BEEN- TOLD OF THAT-
THIS IS- THE FARM BUREAU IN IT
WILL. WILL PROBABLY REMOVE THEIR
CONCERN. ARE GIVEN A LOOK AT THE
AMENDMENTS I HAVEN'T SEEN THEM-
I WILL SAY THIS THAT I DO THINK
THAT UNDER THE CIRCUMSTANCES.
THAT IT IS MUCH MORE COST
EFFICIENT. TO EXPAND PG&E
RESOURCES. WITH RESPECT TO
UNDERGROUNDING. AND A EVENTUALLY
PASSING THAT TO RATE PAYERS. AS
A ONE TIME EXPENDITURE. WHICH
ACHIEVES SIGNIFICANT SAFETY AS
OPPOSED TO THE OTHER ALTERNATIVE
WHICH IS CUTTING TREES FOREVER.
BUT UNTIL THE FARM BUREAU IS
SATISFIED- AND THAT THEIR
CONCERNS ARE MET I'M GOING TO
RESERVE- MY VOTE- HOPE FULLY I
CAN GET TO AN AYE VOTE AT A
LATER TIME. BUT PLEASE WORK THE
FARM BUREAU- AND PLEASE WORK
WITH AGRICULTURE. THANK YOU
READY IT IS FROM MY G. SO- I
THINK OF MR PATTERSON AND I AM
SURE SOME SOME OF THE CONCERNS
HERE GIVEN THAT SOME OF OUR
RECENT DISCUSSIONS ABOUT TO.
ABOUT THE IMPACT OF A LOT FOR
MEDICATION ON ON RATE PAYERS- I
JUST WANNA MAKE SURE I
UNDERSTAND. WHAT YOUR BILL IS
PROPOSING AFTER THE AMENDMENTS-
THAT I SEE MORE BEING ACCEPTED-
SERVICE SO. IT'S REQUIRING THE
I. O. U.'S ALL I ALL USED TO
ADOPT WHAT FIVE MITIGATION PLANS
THAT WOULD- INCLUDE- A MULTI
YEAR UNDERGROUNDING PLAN-
WITHOUT NECESSARILY REQUIRING
ITS ADOPTION. OKAY YES CORRECT.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU. OKAY ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS DR JUST
TO SAY THIS IS A GREAT PAL I
APPRECIATE YOUR WORKING WITH
PG&E LABOR UNIONS CETERA
FANTASTIC BURKE THIS WICKS. WHAT
THE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. OKAY
SEEN NO OTHER QUESTION A COMMENT
IDEA WHATEVER THAT THAT WE
APPRECIATE YOUR TEAM- WORKING
WITH MEMBERS OF THE OF THE TEAM
HERE. I THINK- WHEN THE
CHALLENGES I THINK THAT'S BEEN
EXPRESSED IN AND NOT SO MUCH
BECAUSE THE FARM BUREAU SAYS BUT
BECAUSE I THINK ALL CALIFORNIANS
ARE CONCERNED. ABOUT THE ISSUE
OF- RATE INCREASES RIGHT AND-
THE- I GUESS REMAINING QUESTION
TO BE SEEN IS. HOW ARE WE- MAKE
THIS INVESTMENT WITHOUT FURTHER
IMPACTING THE RATES RIGHT. AND
SO- I GOT A GOOD FEELING FROM
YOUR TEAM IN THE DISCUSSIONS
THAT WE HAD TO GET TO THIS POINT
AND THE AMENDMENTS THAT HAVE
BEEN ACCEPTED THAT- WERE LOOKING
FORWARD TO THE CONTINUING. A
DIALOGUE BUT- JULIET THINK THAT
THE OVERALL CONCERN- WHEN IT'S
ALL SAID AND DONE IS THE ISSUE
OF RATES AND- AND REPAIR SO-
THANK YOU FOR ACCEPTING THOSE
AMENDMENTS AND WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE AND THEN I'LL ENTERTAIN A
MOTION- FROM THE A MEMBERS OF
DICE SURE. I THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN IT AGAIN YOUR STAFF
WORK- AND FOR THE COMMENTS THAT
WERE EXPRESSED HER FROM MY
COLLEAGUES. ABSOLUTELY WANT TO-SIT DOWN WITH THE OPPOSITION AND
MAKE SURE THAT WERE CRAFTING OF
THAT WORK FOR EVERYONE YOU KNOW
MY DISTRICT- WITH MANY OF OUR- A
LOT OF. TO WILDFIRE RIGHT SO. WE
WANT TO WORK COLLABORATIVE LEE
TO INSURE THAT WERE DOING WE
NEED TO DO TO UNDERGROUND ALSO
DOING SO IN A WAY THAT'S REALLY
MINDFUL OF THE CONSUMER DOLLAR-
AND WE KNOW FAMILIES ARE HARD
HIT RIGHT NOW SO THAT'S
OBVIOUSLY VERY CRITICAL
SOMETHING I CARE A LOT ABOUT IT
IN A LOT OF CONSUMER. PROTECTION
WORK IN MY CAREER AS WELL SO.
I'M VERY MINDFUL OF THOSE IT
JUST WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
ADVICE ON I BOUGHT AND ALSO
WILL- OBVIOUSLY PROMISED TO KEEP%
WORKING WITH. THIS IS BUILT INTO
THE PROCESS. THANK YOU. DO WE
HAVE A MOTION FOR THE MOVIE.
MAIENSCHEIN WILL MOTION A SECOND
. AND YOU KNOW THE QUESTIONS-
OR- COMMENTS. PROCOL ITEM NUMBER
FIVE AB TWO EIGHT EIGHT NINE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. EDUARDO GARCIA
HI. EDUARDO GARCIA I PATTERSON.
PATTERSON NOT VOTING PARA QUE
HAN. ERA CAN I CARILLO CARILLO
AYE CHAN. CHEN AYE CUNNINGHAM
CUNNINGHAM I. CRISTINA GARCIA.
HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE IRWIN- WHEN I
MAYES. MURATSUCHI MERCY GI CORK
CORK I REYES. SANTIAGO KING.
NINE ZERO THANK YOU WILL KEEP
THE ROLE OPEN FOR THE MEMBERS AT
ON WORKING ON TO THE LAST TWO
BILLS A. B. TWENTY NINE THIRTY
IN SOME MEMBER CALDERON.
I THOUGHT YOU WERE. THANK.
OKAY SAID THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS I WANT TO FIRST THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
STAFF OF FOR WORKING WITH US ON
THIS BILL WE REALLY APPRECIATE
THE CALL SEN I WILL BE ACCEPTING
ALL OF THE PROPOSED COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS ASSEMBLY BUILT IN
NINE THIRTY SEVEN WOULD
STABILIZE ELECTRICITY RATE
FLUCTUATIONS BY ALLOWING AN
ELECTRIC UTILITY TO REQUEST YOU
THE AUTHORIZATION TO FINANCE
WHILE COMMITTEE EXPENDITURES
INCLUDING THEIR OPERATIONAL AND
MAINTENANCE. TO SEE IS A LOT. OF
PEOPLE YOU. TO SEEK PEACE OUR TO
TAKE BY AND TIE THEM TO REPAIR
BILLS. OR SECURITIZED BONDS TO
PAY FOR JUST AND REASONABLE COST
. AS DETERMINED BY THE PC. WITH
LONGER AND MORE DESTRUCTIVE
WILDFIRE SEASONS ELECTRIC
UTILITIES HAVE INCREASED THEIR
WILDFIRE WILDFIRE MITIGATION
EFFORTS SUCH AS THE VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT. THESE ASSOCIATED
COSTS ARE TYPICALLY REQUIRED TO
BE RECOVERED BY ELECTRIC
UTILITIES WITHIN TWELVE MONTHS.
WITHOUT THE OPTION OF STRETCHING
THE RECOVERY PERIOD WITH
FINANCING MECHANISMS LIKE A BOND
CONSTANT WILDFIRE MITIGATION CAN
LEAD TO MULTIPLE RATE HIKES FOR
RATE PAYERS. THIS BILL IS
SEEKING TO BOLSTER THE CRITERIA
THE PC SHALL UTILIZE WHEN
EVALUATING FUTURE WILDFIRE
MITIGATION SIX SECURITIZATION
REQUEST BY REQUIRING THE
CONSIDER THE SHORT TERM RATE
STABILITY SECURITIZATION.
PROVIDES AS IN THE BEST
INTERESTS FOR RATE PAYERS
PROVIDED THE PC HAS ALREADY
ALLOWED COSTS TO BE AMORTIZED
OVER A PERIOD IN EXCESS OF
TWELVE MONTHS. BEFORE THE BILL
IS PRIORITY MINE AND THE PRIMARY
FOCUS OF THIS BILL. I WANT. THIS
BILL IS NOT SEEKING TO UNDO ANY
PREVIOUS DECISIONS BY THE PC.
AGAIN AB TWENTY NINE THIRTY
SEVEN IS SEEKING TO CHANGE THE
CRITERIA BY WHICH THE PC SHALL
UTILIZE WHEN EVALUATING FUTURE
SECURITIZATION APPLICATIONS.%
HERE WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT IS ADAM SMITH FROM
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA EDISON AND
NIKOLINA HERNANDEZ SAID GAS AND
ELECTRIC. I THINK. GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS OF. ITS WITH
SEVEN EDISON SHARING A STRONG
SUPPORT FOR A BI TWENTY NINE
THIRTY SEVEN S. C. APPLAUDS THE
LEADERSHIP OF THIS COMMITTEE ON
THE ISSUE FOR AFFORDABILITY
WE'VE BEEN HERE FOR THE
COMMITTEE. WE'VE HEARD THE INPUT
QUESTIONS IN PERSON FROM THE
CHAIR AND FROM THE MEMBERS WE'VE
ALL SEEN RATES. IN FOR TO STE.
BIKES AND ARE REFLECTED
CUSTOMERS AND THAT'S WHY WE THEN
S. MEMBER. FOR BRINGING THIS.
BILL FORWARD AND STRONGLY
SUPPORTED TODAY. AS YOU HEARD
FROM THE AUTHOR AB TWENTY NINE
THIRTY SEVEN WOULD ALLOW
ELECTRICAL CORPORATIONS TO FILE
AN APPLICATION. REQUEST THE PEW
TI ISSUE A FINAL. ORDER TO
AUTHORIZE THE RECOVERY OF
WILDFIRE RELATED. TO AN EXPENSE
. CONTACTS IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
S. C. E. N. ORDER. THREE HUNDRED
AND- MILLION DOLLARS IN AND-
WHAT. AN INVITATION AND IT'S NOT
WHAT. ARE WHAT THE FIRE INVEST
MEANT WORK IS NEXT. EVERY IT'S
NICE. FIRST TIME SINCE. WE COULD
NOT. TO FORTY BILL AND WILL
CONTINUE TO IN THE FOR. AB
TWENTY NINE THIRTY PUTS IN PORT
TOOL IN THE TOOLBOX TO SMOOTH
THIS COSTS OVER TIME. THE
LEGISLATURE'S PREVIOUSLY
ESTABLISHED SECURITIZATION AS A
TOOL FOR SPREADING OUT. THE RATE
IMPACT OF OTHER UTILITY WELFARE
COSTS SECURITISATION ALLOWS
UTILITIES TO ACCESS FUNDS
IMMEDIATELY TO START THEIR
IMPORTANT WORK THROUGH THE SALE
OF BONDS WELL SPREADING OUT THE
COST TO. OF THE CHECKS OVER
APPROVED SECURITY. HOWEVER EXIST
FIVE IT WAS MENTIONED NOT
ALLOWED YOU TO CONSIDER THE
BENEFITS OF RATE STABILITY WHEN
EVALUATING WHETHER TO ALLOW AN
ELECTRICAL CORPORATION TO USE
THIS OPTION OR NOT. THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT CONSIDERATION YOUR
COMMITTEE IS DEFINITELY
HIGHLIGHTED THERE ARE A NUMBER
OF FACTORS NATURAL GAS COSTS
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT CENTER
THAT ARE LEADING TO RATE
INCREASES THAT PERSON RIGHT NOW
. THE TEAM THAT USED WANTED TO
SECURE IT SHOULD MAKE SENSE. OR
NOT AND MAKES THE LITTLE WITH
THE PROVED OKAY IF IT DOES. AB
TWENTY THIRTY SEVEN WILL HELP
MANAGE SIGNIFICANT RATES BUT
THAT'S BECAUSE BY YOU NEED
HARDEN THE ELECTRIC SYSTEM
AGAINST WILDFIRE DELAY ON OUR
SHARED. LOS RECENT. DAY THIRTY.
THANK YOU DO I NEED MISS AFFAIRS
FOR GAS AND ELECTRIC SO IT'S A-
WE'RE HERE FOR TO ME PRIOR
NUMBER ONE BEING WHILE FOR MANY
EFFORTS OF WE KNOW THAT
CALIFORNIA'S GETTING HOTTER AND
DRIER AND OUR WELL FOR
MEDICATION INVESTMENTS CAN
COMPREHEND AND THESE EFFORTS ARE
IMPORTANT TO REDO THE RISK THE
SECOND PARTY IS TO MITIGATE TERM
THANKS- WE- OFTEN THE
COMPOUNDING. EFFECTS OF THE
ECONOMY RIGHT NOW INCLUDE-
DEPENDENT SUPPLY CHAIN ISSUES
THE WERE NEW CRANE- THE ECONOMIC
CONTRACTIONS AND THE COST OF
EVERYTHING IS GOING UP SO. JUST
FOR CONTEXT AT FOR AT. R. O. N.
M. COSTS OVER THE LAST TEN YEARS
IS INCREASE BETWEEN THIRTY FIVE
AND 40% SINCE THE SB NINE ONE OF
THE W. M. P. IN OUR WATER
MITIGATION PLAN JUST A TWO YEAR
BETWEEN TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE- THANK THE SAME WERE
PUTTING LOT OF PRESSURE ON OUR
CUSTOMERS. AND WE ALSO PREDICT
THE COST WILL CONTINUE TO
INCREASE IN THE BILLING TO
DOLLARS LARGE. OFFER MEDICATION
COST EXPENSES INCLUDING- NM. AND
TRADITIONALLY- AND M. IS
RECOVERED WITHIN THE YEAR THAT
THAT'S OCCURRED AND THAT'S QUITE
A BETWEEN I THIRTY SEVEN IS SO
IMPORTANT. I'M GIVEN WHAT WE
KNOW ABOUT OUR PLANS TO HARDEN
DISSEMINATE THESE WERE RE. ALEX
AND THE TO TWELVE. OF AND
MECHANISMS- A BETWEEN NINE
THIRTY SEVEN PROVIDES A GREATER
SORTING CLARITY TO BE TO
SECURITIZE WILDFIRE ON THEM.
WELL MAINTAINED WELL MAINTAINED
THE PC'S ABILITY TO DEEM
APPLICATIONS JUST AND
REASONABLE. LEADING THEBROADER
QUESTION IS WHAT IS IN THE
PUBLIC'S INTEREST AND WE
APPRECIATE THE DISCUSSION ON
BALANCING SHORT TERM AND LONG
TERM AFFORDABILITY FOR CUSTOMERS
THIS BILL GIVES I'LL USE AND THE
PC THE OPPORTUNITY- TO MITIGATE
BILL SHOCK. AND ULTIMATELY THAT
HELPS CUSTOMERS WOULD BE FILLED
THE MOST AND THAT'S IN THEIR
POCKETBOOKS AT TO CONCLUDE WE
VERY MUCH THINK THE OTHER FOR
BRINGING THIS MEASURE FORWARD
AND THE COMMITTEE AND THE CHAIR
FOR THE GENEROUS TIME IMPOSING
MMS IN. AND WHAT WE'RE EXPECT
QUESTOR I'VE THINK. WE. FIVE IN
OPPOSITION THEY ARE ON THE PHONE
LINE OPEN MODERATE WE PLAY- BUT
THAT PER. IN THE QUEUE. THE LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU THIS IS MARK TONY EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR TURNED THE UTILITY
REFORM NETWORK THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR OF THE COMMITTEE TURN
STRONGLY OPPOSED THE AB TWENTY
NINE THIRTY SEVEN WE ASK YOU TO
VOTE NO ON ISSUE IN THE NEW
CREDIT CARD I. THE LEGISLATURE
ANYTHING SEND A CLEAR MESSAGE TO
THE P. P. TO PUT THE BRAKES ON
CAIRO RATE INCREASE. AB TWENTY
NINE THIRTY SEVEN IS BAD FOR
RATE PAYERS BECAUSE SPENDING
SECURITIZATION MAKE IT EASIER
FOR THE PDP TO APPROVE RATE
INCREASES TO DATE THAT WILL
BURDEN RATEPAYERS BUT I YOUR
BILL. FOR YEARS TO COME. HE
ALREADY HAS BROUGHT AUTHORITY TO
APPROVE SECURE. OF YOUR COP. SO
THE PC TO REPLY EXISTING INTO
MEASURES TO ADDRESS RATE
STABILITY WHAT SPREADING OUT THE
COP OVER YEARS. SEARCHING OUT AN
ANNUAL CONGRESS SEVERAL YEARS
IT'S LIKE USING CREDIT CARD TO
PAY FOR ITEMS YOU REALLY CAN'T
AFFORD IF UTILITY CLAIMS THAT IT
IS DIFFICULT TO WIN
SECURITIZATION IT'S BECOMING
WOULD BE DIFFICULT TO PROVE THAT
THE BENEFITS SECURITY COOPER
RATE HERE. WENDY THE COFFEE.
RAPIER TURNING MATH WITH THE
SPOT. ANALOG AND WE DON'T HAVE
OPEN OF HUMAN. BONTA HOW YOU
PERMITTING UTILITY PROGRESS I.
SECURITIZE BECAUSE THE TWIN
EIGHTEEN TWAIN WILL MAKE IT
EASIER FOR EVERYTHING THE PATH
OVER A BILLION DOLLARS OF
ADDITIONAL COSTS. SEVEN
CALIFORNIA CUSTOMER THE
LEGISLATURE SHOULD BE MAKING IT
HARDER FOR THE PC TO INCREASE
GREAT NOT EVEN HERE PLEASE VOTE
NO I'M AT TWENTY NINE THIRTY
SEVEN YOU TOO DO NOT NEED A NEW
CREDIT CARD. THANK YOU WE'RE
GOING TO NOW OPEN IT UP PUBLIC.
AND ASK IF THERE ARE MEMBERS OF.
THIS AUDIENCE I WANT TO COME
FORWARD. AND SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE-
PLEASE COME FORWARD AT THIS TIME. SAYING NO ONE COME FORWARD
WE'RE GOING TO. ASK IF THERE ARE
ANY- INDIVIDUALS ON THE PHONE
LINES WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. OR OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF AB
TWENTY NINE THIRTY SEVEN YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
OF AB TWENTY NINE THIRTY SEVEN.
REFERENCE ONE. THE VENDOR. I
HAVE NO COMMENT THANK YOU FOR AB
TWENTY NINE THIRTY SEVEN I THANK
YOU MASK THE- MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE IF THEY HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS PUT TO MY RIGHT FIRST
CUNNINGHAM THAN LEICESTER. YEAH
I WAS. SPEAKING CLARIFICATION
THE COMMITTEE. ON PAGE SIX.
MENTIONS THAT THE COMMITTEE MAY
WISH TO CONSIDER AMENDING THIS
BILL THE MODIFY THE PRESUMPTION
OF PUBLIC INTEREST AND RETAIN
THE CONSIDERATION THAT
SECURITIZED BONDS MUST REDUCE
RATES ARE THOSE AMENDMENTS AND
THEY'VE BEEN ACCEPTED OR THEY'RE
GOING TO BE ACCEPTED. SO THE
DEATHS OF OKAY SO THE AMENDED
VERSION THE BILL. RETAINS THE
CONSIDERATION ABOUT
SECURITIZATION REDUCING RATES
YES OKAY AT THE ENDING THAT'S
IMPORTANT I APPRECIATE THE
ANSWER AND- I DID ACCEPT ALL THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. THE QUESTION
I WANTED TO JOIN MY COLLEAGUE-
WITH RESPECT TO THOSE AMENDMENTS
AND MAKING SURE I'M GONNA
SUPPORT THIS- BEING THERE FRESNO
FOR EIGHT YEARS WE DID A LOT OF
SECURITIZATION WHICH I WAS ABLE
TO- YOU KNOW FINANCE- COSTS AT-
SIGNIFICANTLY LOW. INTEREST
RATES BACK BACK IN NINETY SIX
SEVEN EIGHT TWO THOUSAND POINTS
OUT SO I. UNDERSTAND THE RISK
REWARD FACTOR. OF-
SECURITIZATION I WOULD ALSO
THOUGH SUGGEST THAT GIVEN THE
INFLATIONARY SPIRALS THAT WE ARE
SEEING PRESENTLY. AND GIVEN THE
CLEAR INDICATION FROM THE FED'S
THAT INTEREST RATES ARE GOING UP
. I HAVE A CONCERN THAT CONCERN
IS IT TAKES THE P. YOU SEE AN
AWFUL LONG TIME TO GET ANYTHING
DONE. AND THE LONGER THE P. YOU
SEE TAKES TO APPROVE THE MORE
LIKELY THE INTEREST RATES ARE
GOING UP WHICH CLOSES. THE
LEVERAGE. IT'S A GOOD IDEA TO
BASICALLY FREEZE COSTS AT LOW
INTEREST RATES. BUT I THINK LOW
INTEREST RATES ARE GONNA BE A
THING OF THE PAST. PRETTY SOON.
SO AGAIN I'M GOING TO SUPPORT
THIS. BUT I. HAVE REAL CONCERNS
THAT THE PC IS SO SLOW. IN
MAKING THESE KIND OF
DETERMINATIONS. ARE SO I'M GONNA
GO FOR IT BUT- I SURE HOPE THAT
WE DON'T SEE THIS BY THIS- IN
FRESNO WE SECURITIZED- ARE A
VERY LARGE UNFUNDED LIABILITY IN
OUR- BOB. RETIREMENT ACCOUNTS
AND ALL OF THAT TODAY. BECAUSE
OF THAT FRESNO HAS ONE OF THE
MOST ROBUST AND- SECURE UP. WAYS
OF MAKING SURE THAT OUR WORK
WORK FORCE IT IS DOES GET THE
BENEFITS AND WE CAN AFFORD THOSE
BENEFITS. HOWEVER WE WERE
FORTUNATE BECAUSE WE MADE THE
SECURITIZATION DECISION. AT A
TIME WHEN INTEREST RATES WERE
LIKE AT ONE OR 2% ON. A GENERAL
OBLIGATION BONDS BACK IN THE
NINETIES. THE BET WHAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT HERE. IS THE PRICE TAG
OF THE SEARCH SECURITIZATION.
AND THE SOONER YOU CAN GET IT
DONE. THE LESS LIKELY YOU'RE
GOING TO END UP WITH THE
INTEREST RATES THAT. CLOSE THE
GAP BETWEEN AFFORDABILITY AND
AFFORDABILITY- I DO THINK WE
NEED TO BE CAUTIOUS ABOUT THIS
AND I THINK WE NEED TO BE VERY
CLEAR WITH RESPECT TO THE PC OF
THIS GETS FORWARD IT'S SIGNED BY
THE GOVERNOR THE PC ACT AND ACT
QUICKLY. BECAUSE WE'RE IN A
CIRCUMSTANCE IN WHICH INTEREST
RATES ARE GOING TO SOAR. AND SO
NOW IS THE TIME TO DO IT IF
WE'RE GOING TO DO IT AT ALL. AND
I DO HAVE A CONCERN THAT. IF SIX
MONTHS A YEAR. TWO YEARS GO BY
AND IT TAKES THE P. YOU SEE THAT
KIND OF TIME TO ACT. WE COULD
SEE INTEREST RATES THAT MAKE THE
SECURITIZATION UNAFFORDABLE. AND
ONE FINAL COMMENT I WE HEAR A
LOT ABOUT CONCERNS. HERE I'D
LIKE I'D BEEN ON THIS COMMITTEE
WHAT NINE YEARS GOING ON TEN
YEARS I HAVE WARNED ABOUT TWO
THINGS THE GREAT BECOMING
INCREASINGLY UNRELIABLE AND THE
COST OF ELECTRICITY SPRING AND
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT HAS HAPPENED
. WE SAY WE CARE ABOUT
RELIABILITY WE SAY WE CARE ABOUT
RATES AND YET SESSION AFTER
SESSION. WE CREATE IMPEDIMENTS.
TO RELIABILITY AND IMPEDIMENTS
TO AFFORDABILITY. SO I THINK
THIS IS THE RIGHT THING TO DO.
BUT IT BETTER BE ABLE TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF A WINDOW OF
SOMEWHAT LOW INTEREST RATES.
BECAUSE PRETTY SOON THOSE
INTEREST RATES ARE GOING TO SORT
. THANK YOU- AS FAR CAN FOLLOW
BY MR MURATSUCHI THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I JUST HAD A
QUESTION FOR THE AUTHOR I GUESS
SUPPORTERS IF THEY WANT TO
ANSWER SO THE I THINK THIS IS AN
ADDRESS FOR A TWENTY
CLARIFICATION WHICH IS IN THE-
ABILITIES SECURITIZED IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN WILDFIRE COST THE
STANDARD HERE IS JUST THAT THE
P. YOU SEE FIND THAT REASONABLE
BUT IT SEEMS LIKE A SORT OF A
LOWER STANDARD THAN IS USUAL FOR
SECURITIZATION WHICH I THINK IS
AN ESTIMATES COMMITTEE BUT I
JUST WANTED CLARIFICATION.
EXCEPT HOW IS IT ADDRESSED IT
IMMEDIATELY TO WE- WE TOOK THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS TO AT JUST
AND REASONABLE WHICH IS THE
USUAL WAY IT'S DRAFTED AGAIN
KIND OF FROM USUAL. OKAY YOU SEE
APPRECIATE THAT THANK YOU. MR
MURATSUCHI. THANK YOU I AM
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S INTENT
TO WITH THE SAY IT BEING OF
LIGHT MANY OF US ON THIS
COMMITTEE WE ARE WE ALL AND I'M
SURE THE AUTHOR TO WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE WE GET IT RIGHT- SO IF
I MAY WITH. CHAIRS PERMISSION I
I'D LIKE TO ASK A MISTER TONY TO
BE- I'D LIKE TO ADDRESS SOME
QUESTIONS FOR MISTER TONY TONY
STILL ON. YEP THANK YOU. SO OF
MISTER JORDAN TONY I JUST
RECEIVED YOUR TURN LETTER AND
THAT'S WHY I DIDN'T RAISE
CONCERNS. ACCORDING TO THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS AND ACCORDING
TO THE TESTIMONY OF THE
COMMITTEE THE S. AND AMENDMENT
OF THE HAS BEEN TAKEN. TO- TO
REQUIRE THAT THAT- THAT
SECURITIZED BONDS MUST REDUCE-
OUR ROOM RATES PAYER RIGHT. DOES
THAT ADDRESS YOUR CONCERN. OUR
VISION IS THAT THIS IS THE BILL
THAT'S NOT NEEDED P. THREE
ALREADY HAVE AUTHORITY TO
APPROVE SECURITIZATION THAT THIS
BILL MAKES IT EASIER IT IS
SENDING A MESSAGE FROM THE
LEGISLATURE THAT YOU WANT THE P.
THREE TO APPROVE MORE WE DO
BELIEVE THAT SECURITIZATION DOES
HAVE AN APPROPRIATE PLACE I DO
THINK BREAK A CAR. AND ACTUALLY
. COSTS IN WHICH THE BENEFIT
WILL BE EXPERIENCED OVER THE
SAME AMOUNT OF TIME THAT WE'RE
SPENDING FOR IT THE IDEA THAT
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE A CAR FOR
FIFTY YEARS THAT'S WHAT MAKES
SENSE TO ASK. SIX YEARS. WE
PARTICULARLY AFTER THE I. OF THE
EYE OF TAKING IN ANY LOOK A
OPERATE AND MAINTENANCE COSTS
WHICH OCCURRED SINGLE AND THEN
HE THAT OUT OVER FIVE OR TEN
THAT WE GET INTO TROUBLE WITH
CREDIT CARDS AND WITH
SECURITIZATION WHEN YOU TRY TO
PICTURE IT ANNUAL CONFERENCE
OVER AND OVER AGAIN. THAT'S WHEN
YOU START GETTING THE BILL TO.
BUT MR TONY IF THIS BILL IS
GOING TO. PROHIBIT THE P. YOU
SEE FROM A POOR APPROVING ANY
BONDS TO BE APPROVED THAT WOULD
RESULT IN A- INCREASE TO RATE
PAYERS WOULDN'T THAT SATISFY
YOUR OBJECTIVE. IT IT COULD BE
FOR A QUESTION OF A INCREASE.
OVER THERE WILL BE AN INCREASE
IT A COMPARISON BETWEEN N. FOR
IT DURING THAT FELT THE SAME
TWELVE MONTHS AND PAYING FOR IT
OVER TIME TO TAKE THE CAR
ANALOGY- OF COURSE IF YOU PAY
FOR A CAR OVER SHAKESPEARE IT'S
GONNA LEFT. HER MIND THEN IF YOU
PAY FOR IT ALL AT ONCE EIGHT FOR
THE FIRST MONTH OF COURSE BUT
YOU'RE ALSO GOING TO BE PAYING.
A GREATER AMOUNT IN TOTAL
BECAUSE OF THE INTEREST CAR
BECAUSE OF THE COST OF FINANCING
THAT'S WHY WE DON'T THINK THAT
SIMPLY SAYING IT WILL REDUCE
WEIGHT PAYER COSTS FROM WHAT IT
WOULD HAVE BEEN IS A HIGH ENOUGH
THEN. SO THEN I GUESS I WOULD
HAVE A QUESTION EITHER FOR THE
AUTHOR OF THE COMMITTEE I MEAN
DOES THIS BILL- WHICH WILL
ENSURE YOU KNOW. THAT THAT THE
COST IMPOSED ON RATEPAYER OVER A
REPAIRS OVER TIME WHAT WOULD NOT
BE- INCREASED AS A RESULT OF
BEING OF THE SECURITIZE.
OPERATIONS AND MAINTENANCE
EXPENSE- HE HAD. YEAH FROM THE I
MEAN JUST JUST BE SPEAK VERY
PLAINLY THE AMENDMENT THAT WE
TOOK FROM THE COMMITTEE
ADDRESSES EXACTLY WHAT YOU
SUGGEST THAT IT IT SURE IS THAT
THIS IS IN THE PUBLIC INTEREST
ALL THE COSTS ARE STILL JUST AND
REASONABLE THE EXISTING
FRAMEWORK AND DISCUSSION OF THE
PC IS ALWAYS THERE TO UNDERSTAND
WHETHER OR NOT YOU KNOW THE- THE
SHIP THAT SHORT TERM RATES
MOVING BENEFITS OF OUR THE
PROPOSAL HERE. ARE BALANCED IN
RELATION TO THE LONG TERM TOTAL
COSTS A TO USE MR ANALOGY OF
OWNING THE CAR AND ONLY THE
SITUATIONS WITH THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION WOULD FIND
THAT IT IS IN THE BEST INTEREST
WEARING THE SHORT TERM BENEFITS
OF MAYBE RATES MOVING IN THE
NEAR TERM OR LOCKING AND KIND OF
AS VICE CHAIR SUGGESTED KIND
COURT COSTS AT A LOW INTEREST
RATE. IF THAT BALANCED OUT WITH
THE- THE LONG TERM TOTAL COST
INCREASES RIGHT OR INTEREST
COSTS THERE. THE PC HAS IT
WITHIN ITS DISCRETION TO FIGURE
OUT THE RIGHT BALANCE AND
EITHER. OR DENY THAT'S THE CORE
PIECE HERE I THINK THE EXISTING
FRAMEWORK ALL STAYS IN PLACE.
THEY HAVE THE DISCRETION AND
THAT OF MINUTES WE TOOK FROM
COMMITTEE OR WHICH I THINK WERE
VERY WELL RECEIVED ON OUR PART
WE THINK THIS GOOD.
CLARIFICATION JUST TO MAKE SURE
IN THE EYES OF THE COMMITTEES
VOTING ON THIS TODAY THAT IT IS
GOING TO REDUCE RATES AS WITH
THE PC. IS GOING TO BE IN CHARGE
OF DOING MCCARTY DOES. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. YEAH I GET I THINK
THAT'S A REASONABLE LA. RESPONSE
TO THAT THE TERM CONCERNS I DO
WANT TO EXPLORE. THE NATURE OF
FINANCE INSTRUMENTS THAT WILL BE
USED. OP WHAT WILL BE THE
SOURCE. OF THE REPAYMENT. YEAH
IF IT DOES NOT WAS AYE AYE WHAT
I WANT TO TRY TO GET TO HERE'S
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN A-
REVENUE BASE BOND AND A GENERAL
OBLIGATION BOND AND IN
GOVERNMENT GENERAL OBLIGATION
BONDS COME AT. FIRST CALL-
REVENUE BASE BONDS HAVE A
SATISFACTORY STREAM OF- PAYMENT-
AND THOUGH THE RATING
INSTRUMENTS PROCESS THAT. I
WOULD LIKE TO KNOW WHAT KIND OF
A- INSTRUMENT THE UTILITIES WILL
USE. TO SECURITIZE IS IT BACK BY
RATES OR IS IT BACK BY THEIR
GENERAL FUND. I'M HAPPY TO PICK
UP THE TICKET YES IT'S BACKED BY
RATES AND THAT'S ONE OF THE CORE
BENEFITS HERE IS THAT WHEN IT'S
BACKED BY RATES WE CAN ACTUALLY
ACCESS THAT CAPITAL THAT THE
LARGE SUMS THAT WE'RE SEEKING TO
KIND OF HELP REDUCE RATES THAT
AND PAY OFF SOME THESE WELFARE.
EXPENSES AT A LOWER COST THAN IF
WE WERE TO TRY TO GO OUT THERE
IN THE CORPORATE BOND MARKET AND
ACCESS THOSE AND SO THAT SORT OF
ONE OF THE CORE OPPORTUNITIES
HERE I THINK YOU HIGHLIGHTED
INTEREST RATES ARE LOW RIGHT NOW
BUT WE WOULD SUGGEST THAT
INTEREST RATES FOR SECURITIZED
WHEN WE WHEN E SECURITIZE ARE
ALWAYS LOWER THAN WHAT WE WOULD
BE ABLE TO SEE USING OUR OWN
KIND OF BONDING AUTHORITY THAT
WOULD HAVE AS A CORPORATION.
BECAUSE OF OUR- FINANCIAL HEALTH
BASED UPON THE- BROADER WILDFIRE
DISCUSSIONS WITH CONTINUED
HAPPENS COMMITTEE FOR A NUMBER
OF YEARS. SO THAT'S WHERE WE
VIEW SECURITIZATIONS OPPORTUNITY
IT'S KIND OF ALWAYS GOING TO BE.
CHEAPER FOR OUR CUSTOMERS THAN
JUST GOING ALL STRAIGHT THROUGH
BONDS AND STUFF. OUR OWN
CORPORATE DOES THAT. SATISFY
THE- I'M HAPPY TO FOLLOW UP TO
BECAUSE I'M JUST BE. WITH US IF
YOU WANT TO GET INTO THE DETAILS
ABOUT YOUR EX WILL GET YOU TO
GO. AGAIN I THOUGHT. ALL OF THIS
MAKES SENSE IF. THE INTEREST
RATES PROVIDE A LEVERAGE OF.
REPRODUCTION IF THE INTEREST
RATES. SPIKE IT CLOSES THAT
LEVERAGE. AT AND- AT AND I WILL
GO BACK TO THE- RISKS THAT WE
TOOK. IN SECURITIZED IN OUR
UNFUNDED LIABILITY. AND WE WERE
VERY FORTUNATE WE HAD GOOD
ANALYSTS AND WE WENT INTO THAT
MARKET AT LIKE I DON'T KNOW 2%
SOMETHING LIKE THAT. WE WERE
UNDER A COURT ORDER. TO FULFILL
THE OBLIGATION TO OUR RETIREES.
SAID SOMETHING LIKE SIX OR SEVEN
PERCENT. SO OBVIOUSLY WE
LEVERAGED. AND DOWN. SIZE THE
COST TODAY. FRESNO HAS- IS
HIGHLY REGARDED AS ONE OF THE
FEW CITIES. THAT HAS A FULLY
FUNDED- RETIREMENT SYSTEM PARTLY
AS A RESULT OF. BEING FORTUNATE
BEING BEING A BIT PROPHETIC WITH
RESPECT WERE PLANNING. BUT ALSO
SORT OF LOOKING OUT. I AM
CONCERNED ABOUT THE TIME LAG
IT'S GOING TO TAKE BETWEEN THE
TIME WE APPROVE THIS IT GETS
SIGNED AND IT'S LAW. TO WIN THE
P. YOU SEE WILL ACT AND I DON'T
WANT TO BE SITTING HERE SIX
MONTHS OR A YEAR FROM NOW SEEING
INTEREST RATES SO HIGH THAT YOU
CANNOT CLOSE THE GAP. AND THE
LEVERAGE IS GONE SO THERE'S A
REAL RISK HERE. AND IT HAS TO DO
WITH THE INTEREST RATES ON THE
PRICE TAG OF A BORROWED MONEY
AND WHO KNOWS WHERE THAT'S GOING
TO GO. SO I'M GOING TO VOTE FOR
THIS AND HOPE THAT THE P. YOU
SEE ACTS QUICKLY AND YOU CAN
SECURITIZE AT LOW RATES IF NOT
THIS DOESN'T WORK. WE HAVE TO
MEMBERS THAT WITH SOCIAL
QUESTIONS THAT WAS GÓMEZ REYES
FOLLOWED BY MISS GARCIA. THANK
YOU. I HAVE A FEW QUESTIONS- FEW
CONCERNS I WILL BE SUPPORTING
THE BILL TODAY BUT I DO HAVE
SOME CONCERNS- AS YOU MAY KNOW I
SAID ON THE CONFERENCE COMMITTEE
FOR WILDFIRES ALSO WORKED-
DILIGENTLY ON SB NINE OH ONE.
WITH ROBUST DISCUSSION WITH ALL
OF THE I. O. U.'S.
SECURITIZATION WAS ALLOWED
DISSLY AND IT THE CONDITIONS
THAT HAVE TO BE SATISFIED ARE
LISTED AS TO WHAT NEEDS TO BE
DONE. BUT EVEN BEFORE WE GET TO
THAT THE ARE YOU- YOU HAD TO
ESTABLISH A STANDARD OF
REASONABLE CONDUCT. THERE WAS
SERIOUS QUESTION FOR THE YEAR
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN REGARDING
THE NEGLIGENCE OF THE I'LL USE
AND THAT WAS A THRESHOLD THAT
HAVE TO BE OVERCOME BEFORE WE
EVER TALKED ABOUT JUST AND
REASONABLE. THAT IS A CONCERN
THAT I HAVE REGARDING- WHAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT TODAY THE
EMPHASIS HAS BEEN ON
SECURITISATION BUT I THINK EVEN
BEFORE WE GET TO SECURITIZATION.
IT'S DETERMINING WHETHER IT IS
THE FACT THAT IT ONLY SAID
REASONABLE FOR I'M GLAD THE I AM
VERY GLAD THAT THE AMENDMENT WAS
ACCEPTED BECAUSE THAT WAS A
STANDARD THAT WAS PUT IN NINE TO
ONE. THE WHEN WE LOOK EVEN IF
THE ANALYSIS WHICH WAS. VERY
WELL DONE. AND WE LOOK AT THE
EXISTING LAW EXISTING LAW ALLOWS
FOR THIS BUT EXISTING LAW ALSO
REQUIRES THE STANDARD OF
REASONABLE CONDUCT OF THE- I OWE
YOU BEFORE THEY CAN EVER GET TO
THAT. BECAUSE IF THEIR CONDUCT
WAS NOT REASONABLE. FOR THAT
PARTICULAR WILDFIRE. THEN
THEY'RE NOT ABLE TO GET TO THE
SECOND STEP OF JUST AND
REASONABLE THAT THEN ALLOWS YOU
TO GET TO SECURITIZATION. SO I
IT'S AN OUTSTANDING ISSUE I WILL
BE SPEAKING WITH THE AUTHOR AND
WITH OTHERS WHO HAVE OFFERED TO.
TO WALK ME THROUGH THIS AGAIN-
BUT IT IS A CONCERN SO FOR TODAY
I WILL BE SUPPORTING IT AND
BEFORE WE GET ON THE FLOOR I
KNOW THAT YOU AND I WILL HAVE
MORE CONVERSATIONS YEAH. THANK
YOU FOR THAT AND I WE WILL. WE
CAN DISCUSS IT THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR THANK YOU. THE MEMBERSHIP.
YES THANK YOU I HAD BEEN ASKING
WHERE THAT TURNED LETTER WAS AND
SO FINALLY THAT CA- AND IN SO
CAN WE- AND I APOLOGIZE IF I GOT
HERE LEAD TO THE SPREAD OF
ALREADY BEEN COVER CAN WE-
QUICKLY GO OVER THE AMENDMENTS
THAT WERE TAKEN AND COMMITTEE.
THAT'S MY FIRST QUESTION THAT I
THE PUBLIC PLACE TO. SO WE HAVE
BUT THREE PARTICULAR AMENDMENTS
THAT ARE HIGHLIGHTED AS THE
FIRST REMOVED CLIMATE ADAPTATION
COSTS EXPENSES CHANGE A
CONSIDERATION THAT SECURITIZED
BONDS MOMENT MUST REDUCE RATES
CLARIFIES THAT THE PRESUMPTION
OF SHORT TERM RATE STABILITY WAS
ONLY IF THE CPUC AUTHORIZE THOSE
COSTS TO BE PAID DOWN UNDER
TRADITIONAL MEANS- THOSE ARE THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WE'RE PUTTING
FORWARD AND THEY HAVE BEEN
ACCEPTED BY THE AUTHOR. OKAY SO
F. AS I'M READING THE LETTER
FROM TURN A BIG PART OF IT WAS
AROUND CLIMATE ADAPTATION AND
THAT'S BEEN REMOVED SO THAT'S
BEEN ADDRESSED- A PART OF IT-
WITH. MAKES SENSE ABOUT MAKING
SURE THAT RATES ARE GOING TO BE
REDUCED TO A WHICH IS I THINK
AND- BUT THEN THE MISSION THERE.
ARE AND THEN THEY'RE STILL THE
PENDING QUESTIONS AND I THINK A
LITTLE BIT ALIGNED BUT NOT
EXACTLY WHERE- WHAT ARE.
MAJORITY LEADER WAS TALKING
ABOUT THE CATASTROPHIC FIRES OF
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN AND ALL
THAT WORK THAT WAS DONE THROUGH
THAT WORKING GROUP THAT
CONFERENCE IN. THE BILL THAT WE
EVENTUALLY HAD. INSIDE I DO HOPE
YOU CAN GET TO A PLACE WHERE WE
CAN FIND- COMMON GROUND WITH
TURN IT DOWN A LOT OF WORK IN
THAT DIRECTION ALREADY AND I
WANT TO A KNOWLEDGE. THAT WITH
THESE EVENTS AND APART BE EIGHT
THAT- I WILL SAY THAT- SHORT
TERM REDUCE YOUR RATE SOUNDS
GREAT. LONG TERM THE REST WITH
THE VERY. WITH INTEREST RATES
SHIFTING AN- HOUR THAT MEANS
THAT THE SCARE ME SOMETIMES AS
THE LAST LOOK AT THESE MECHANICS
AND THE RISKS THAT ARE. THAT ARE
THERE. AND SOME A LITTLE BIT
UNCOMFORTABLE WITH WITH SOME OF
THIS SCHEMATICS OF THIS BILL
BUT- I AM COMFORTABLE ENOUGH TO
VOTE FOR IT. AT TODAY. THE ONE
THING I DO KNOW IS THAT RATES
ARE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
INCREASE THIS YEAR ALONE WE SEE
MULTIPLE RATE INCREASES. AT THE
VETS HAVE HAVE BEEN. TALKING TO
US AND WHETHER OR NOT THIS IT'S
OVER GOING TO BE ABLE TO YOU
AFFECTED I THINK A FAIR. FAIR
QUESTION THAT WITH THE PATTERSON
IS SPRINGING UP- AS WELL AND NO
NO WE CAN'T USE THAT THIS WHOLE
DISCUSSION IS MOOT ANYWAY SINCE-
RATES WILL NOT BE ABLE TO BE
LARGE ENOUGH ANYWAY SPENT
THINKING. BECAUSE YOU SAID MR
PATTERSON'S NAME ME WANTS TO SAY
SOMETHING AYE AYES RIGHT LET HIM
GOOD QUESTION- I KNOW THAT.
THERE IS A DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
REDUCING RATES. AND REDUCING THE
INCREASE OF THE RATES. I WANT TO
KNOW THAT THIS REDUCES RATES.
AND NOT MERELY REDUCES THE
POTENTIAL INCREASE IN THE RATES
. CAN YOU SPEAK TO THAT PLEASE.
YEAH I'M HAPPY TO UP TO BE
TOTALLY CANDID I MEAN I THINK IF
YOU LOOK AT THE REDUCTION OF
ELECTRICITY RATES. SPREADING OUT
THE COST A BIG CHUNK OF COSTS
OVER MORE TIME IN YEAR ONE TWO
THREE AT CETERA WILL REDUCE
RATES. THE THING IS IT'S VERY
DIFFICULT ALL THESE COSTS WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT REAL COST
NECESSARY COSTS WHILE FOR
HARDENING IT CETERA THOSE ARE
GOING TO HAVE TO BE RECOVERED.
THROUGH CUSTOMERS THAT'S THE
REGULATORY COMPACT THAT'S THE
TIME WE HAVE. I WOULD SAY THAT
THE ALTERNATIVE TO SPREADING IT
OUT BE A SECURITIZATION IS
AMORTIZATION AND GETTING IT OVER
A MUCH SHORTER TIME PERIOD SO
IT'S HIGHER SO. I WOULD SAY THE
SAME ABOUT BUCKET ACOSTA IF YOU
SPREAD IT OUT OVER. THE RATES
MOVING THING WE'VE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT IT'S GOING TO REDUCE RATES
FOR CUSTOMERS IN THE EARLY YEARS
IT'S JUST LIKE BUYING A CAR IF
YOU PAY YOU KNOW FULL PRICE AT
THE DOOR IT'S VERY EXPENSIVE ALL
UP FRONT. DO YOU THAT DO USE
MISTER TONY'S ALLERGY OVER TIME
THAT YOU KNOW THE INCREMENTAL IT
YOU KNOW PAYMENT EVERY SINGLE
YEAR IS MUCH LOWER SO THAT'S THE
WAY WE VIEW AND THAT'S WHY WE
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR THE
COMMITTEE TO BE THINKING ABOUT
THIS THANKS. JUST SO MANY RATE
PRESSURES COMING ALL AT ONCE CAN
SOMEONEPLEASE BE SPREAD OUT
OVER TIME. THE PC TERMS WITH THE
DISCRETION OF THE RIGHT KIND OF
CONSIDERATIONS FROM YOU GUYS
THAT IT IS IN THE PUBLIC
INTEREST IT'S- THANK. I'M AGAIN
I. WILL I MEAN IF THIS IS
ACTUALIZED. WILL THE BASIC
KILOWATT HOUR RATE GO DOWN. OR
WILL YOU BE YOUR YOU'RE YOU'RE-
COMMITTING THAT THAT'S GONNA
HAPPEN. WHAT YEAH WHAT WHAT
WE'RE JUST SAYING IS THESE COSTS
ARE BIG THE PC EVERYTHING WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT HAS ALREADY
DETERMINED THAT RECOVERING THOSE
FROM CUSTOMER. WHETHER THE
DECISION THAT THIS BILL KIND OF
PROMPTS AT RBI'S ACTION AYE
OVERTIME WORK ALL RIGHT I'M
GONNA TELL YOU WHAT I'M HEARING
YEAH. WHAT I'M HEARING IS THE
COST TO REPAIR YEAH. MY FRIENDS
GOING TO BE EX YEAH. AND IF YOU
AMORTIZE THEM IT'S GOING TO BE
X. MINUS SOMETHING THAT'S
CORRECT YEP. I WISH I WISH I HAD
CONFIDENCE IN THAT I. LOOK I'VE
BEEN HERE NINE YEARS GOING ON
TEN YEARS EVERY TIME WE GO AT
THESE RATE REDUCTIONS. IT
BASICALLY IS WELL IT WOULD HAVE
GONE UP THIS MUCH BUT LOOK WHAT
WE DID IT ONLY WENT UP THIS
MONTH. IT THIS MUCH. AND I CAN
TELL YOU. UP CENTRAL CALIFORNIA
. RECEIVED SOME OF THE HIGHEST
ELECTRICITY BILLS MY OFFICE WAS
FLOODED WITH CONCERNS WHAT
HAPPENED HERE. RIGHT SO I'M BUT
YOU KNOW THAT WITH IN MANY
RESPECTS WE ARE MAKING A LEAP OF
FAITH HERE. AND WHEN U. S.
BUYING AN AUTOMOBILE. YEAH
THERE'S A LOT OF OFFERS OUT
THERE WHERE YOU CAN DO ZERO
INTEREST APPOINT NINE NINE. BUT
YEAH SOMETHING ELSE THERE 6% 7%
8% LOANS OUT THERE. IF YOU GOT A
CREDIT RATING THAT'S NOT QUITE
SO I. YOU KNOW I'M GOING TO VOTE
FOR THIS BUT WE'RE AT A
CROSSROADS WHERE WE BETTER ACT
WITH THE AMORTIZATION NEEDS TO
BE A LOW INTEREST RATE. AND IN
FACT RATES NEED TO COME DOWN NOT
MERELY THE GROWTH OF INTEREST OF
RATE INCREASES. COME DOWN. THAT
THAT THAT'S THAT'S JUST PLAIN
WITH SEMANTICS ARE RATE PAYERS
NEED RELIEF. THIS BETTER PROVIDE. WHICH MURATSUCHI WELL THANK
YOU KNOW WE JUST TO FOLLOW UP ON
MISTER PATTERSON'S LINE OF
QUESTIONING I MEAN I THINK
THAT'S WHERE USUALLY GOOD
LAWYERS COME INTO PLAY. RATHER
THAN JUST RELYING ON THE GOOD
FAITH OF THE UTILITIES THAT THAT
WE SHOULD MAKE SURE THAT THE
LANGUAGE YOU KNOW SPELLS OUT
EXACTLY WHAT WHAT YOU WANT I.
ADMIT I HAVEN'T. LOOK AT THE
LANGUAGE I'M RELYING ON THE- THE
COMMITTEE TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY'LL- A LOT AS TO WHAT WE
NEED BUT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
LANGUAGE REQUIRES. THAT THAT
IT'S A SPELLS OUT EXACTLY WHAT
YOU'RE WHAT YOU'RE CALLING FOR
MY QUESTION AND EVEN THOUGH WE
LOST TO MS REYES MAY HAVE
WITNESSED HOLDEN- MR HOLDEN- A
YOU KNOW WHO WHO WAS PART OF
THE- SB NINE OH ONE DISCUSSIONS
. YEAH SHE SHE RAISE THE POINT
THAT THE CAR. COULD NOT BE ARE
SECURITIZED. YOU KNOW WITHOUT A
SHOWING THAT THE UTILITIES
DEMONSTRATE REASONABLE DOUBT SO
IN OTHER WORDS THEY WOULD BE
ABLE TO. TO IS SECURITIZED COSTS
THAT THE THAT THAT WERE INCURRED
YOU KNOW THROUGH. BASICALLY
IRRESPONSIBLE CONDUCT OR
NEGLIGENCE ON THE PART OF THE
UTILITY- AND SO YOU GET SHE SHE
IS THE AUTHOR COMMITTED TO
FOLLOWING UP WITH MATH OF MS
REYES BUT I WANTED TO HEAR THE
UTILITIES RESPONSE. TO MS RACES
QUESTION. WITH YEAH YEAH I'M I'M
HAPPY TO GO- WE WERE RT AND VERY
MUCH INVOLVED IN THE S. B. NINE
A ONE MAYBE TEN FIFTY FOUR. AD
SUPPORTED THAT CAJUN THANK- THE
FORMER CHAIR HOLDEN FOR ALL THIS
WORK ON ON THAT WE VIEW THIS
THIS LEGISLATION AS NOT TOUCHING
THE REASONABLENESS STANDARD AND
THE REALLY BALANCED AND YOU KNOW
WHAT WELL THOUGHT THROUGH.
BALANCE AT THAT. THOSE BILLS
BASICALLY TOOK WILL ALL THAT'S
ASIDE- THIS JUST IS A BILL THAT
FOCUSES ON IF THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION DETERMINES.
THAT THE COSTS ARE JUST AND
REASONABLE AND THEREFORE WILL BE
RECOVERED FROM OUR CUSTOMERS AT
THE PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION
HAS IN ITS TOOLBOX THE ABILITY
TO NOT LOOK AT JUST SPREADING IT
OVER A- YEAR TWO YEARS THREE
YEARS. BUT USING THE
SECURITIZATION TOOL TO SPREAD IT
OUT MUCH LONGER SO WE ARE IN NO
WAY ACTIVELY TOUCHING THE
REASONABLE STANDARD OR THE
DELICATE BALANCE THAT WAS STRUCK
IN THE RIBS A LOT OF
CONVERSATIONS. HAVE MEMBERS
INCLUDING ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAISES
TIME ON THAT. THAT'S ALL TO THE
SIDE WE'RE ACCEPTING THAT AS A
GIVEN. THE OUTCOME FROM THE PC
PC DETERMINATION NOT. INFORMED
IF WE EVEN OPERATE IN THAT
TWENTY EIGHTEEN SECTION OF THE
BILL OR NOT ARCTIC. ANYONE ELSE
WANNA. WEIGH IN. TO MY RIGHT
LEFT TO CHERISH. ALL RIGHT WE
HAVE A MOTION TO MOVE THE BILL.
OTHER AS ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS THE SECOND BUSINESS
CARE ABOUT. BAUER CAN- LOW
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS WAS FOR-
CLOSING. AND AND THEN ROLL CALL
YES- I GREATLY APPRECIATE THE
DISCUSSION ON THIS BILL I THINK
IT IS VERY HELPFUL AND- YET YES
SOME GOOD QUESTIONS. AND I JUST
WANT TO REITERATE HOW MUCH I
APPRECIATE- THE COMMITTEE'S
WILLINGNESS TO WORK WITH US ON
THIS AND YOUR CONSIDERATION
MISTER CHAIR SO I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
HEY TO ARE RECOGNIZED AS A TIME
PUT INTO THE WEE HOURS OF THE
NIGHT. YESTERDAY IN TRYING TO.
GET SOME- ADVANCEMENT ON THESE
QUESTIONS THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED-
TODAY BY THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE SO THANK YOU FOR WILL
CALL QUESTION. I AM NUMBER SIX
A. B. TWO NINE THREE SEVEN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS EDUARDO GARCIA.
EDUARDO GARCIA I PATTERSON.
PATTERSON I BARRICADED. R. K.
HAND EYE CARILLO CARILLO I CHEN
. CHEN I CUNNINGHAM. CRISTINA
GARCIA CRISTINA GARCIA HI HOLDEN
HOLDEN AYE IRWIN- WHEN I MAYES.
MAYES I AM RESEARCHING
MURATSUCHI I CORK REYES SANTIAGO
KING. THAT'S TEN BELIEVE THE
ROLE OPEN FOR THE MEMBERS TO ADD
ON FINAL BILLS ITEM SEVEN AB
TWENTY SEVENTY OR COMMITTEE KALI
OUR QUE HAN THANK YOU. NICE WORK.
PLEASE PROCEED THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS- I WANT TO
START BY THANKING THE COMMITTEE
STAFF AND THE CHAIR FOR THEIR-
ELABORATION ON THIS BILL AND
WANT TO BE CLEAR THAT I'M
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS WHICH WILL
STRIKE D. ENERGIES VISION EVENTS
FROM NOTICE REQUIREMENTS.
EXPANDS THE BILL TO PUBLICLY
OWNED UTILITIES AND CLARIFY THE
UTILITIES WILL NOT BE REQUIRED
TO PAY ANY FEES PRE POSITIONING
EVERY. FIRE DISTRICTS WHICH
SHOULD ADDRESS THE ISSUES RAISED
IN THE ANALYSIS- I WITH THAT
TODAY I AM PROUD TO PRESENT AB
TWENTY SEVENTY MY DISTRICT AND
MY HOME SET ON THE WILDLAND
URBAN INTERFACE WE FACE WINS
SPECIFICALLY BE DIABLO WINDS
DURING MANY POINTS DURING THE
YEAR OUR HOUSES BACK UP TO OPEN
SPACE IT'S FILLED WITH DRIED
GRASS AT THOSE MOMENTS WHEN A
SPARK FLIES IN THE WIND IS GOING
WE KNOW WHAT COULD HAPPEN NEXT
WHICH IS A SIGNIFICANT WILDFIRE
WE HAVE INCREDIBLE FIRE CHIEFS
IN OUR COMMUNITY TO WORK
TIRELESSLY TO ENSURE THAT THEY
HAVE THE RESOURCES AT THE READY
IF SOMETHING LIKE THAT WERE TO
OCCUR YOU'LL HEAR FROM TWO OF
THEM TODAY. AND WHAT THIS BILL
DOES IS ACTUALLY VERY SIMPLE HE
GIVES OUR FIRE CHIEFS THE TOOLS
TO PRE POSITION WHEN HOT WORK
WHICH COULD CAUSE THOSE SPARKS
THAT I MENTIONED TO FLY IN THESE
HIGH FIRE ZONES IT ALLOWSOUR
FIRE CHIEF SAYS YOU'LL HEAR TO
SANTA CRUZ I BY HER NOTHING IS
WRONG IT NO WAY THEIR CREW
SHOULD BE IF SOMETHING WERE TO
HAPPEN THIS WORK IS NECESSARY
NOTHING IN THIS BILL STOPS THIS
WORK FROM OCCURRING IN FACT. THE
BILL SPECIFIES THAT IF THE WORK
IS URGENT AND NOTICE IS NOT
REQUIRED TO TWENTY FOUR HOURS
NOTICE WE ARE NOT INTENDING TO
STOP THE BURKE MERELY TRYING TO
GIVE OUR FIRE CHIEFS THE TOOLS
TO BE PREPARED IF A FIRE WERE TO
START FROM THE WORK THAT
HAPPENED SO THEY CAN PUT IT OUT
QUICKLY. EVERYONE OF A KNOWS THE
ONE A FIRE STARTED TIME IS
ABSOLUTELY OF THE ESSENCE
ESPECIALLY. IN THESE HIGH FIRE
ZONES. OUR CHIEFS AND I BELIEVE
THAT THIS CAN PROTECT OUR
COMMUNITIES AND ENSURE. THAT
WE'RE SAVING LIVES AND SAVING
HOMES IN OUR COMMUNITIES IT'S
THEIR REQUIREMENT HERE IS.
INCREDIBLY SIMPLE IT REQUIRES A
PHONE CALL AND EMAIL. THESE
CREWS ARE BEING TOLD TO GO OUT
AND OUR FIRE CHIEFS JUST ONE
NOTICE THAT THIS WORK IS
HAPPENING. SO WE DON'T THINK THE
BURDEN IS TOO HIGH TO ASK. WE
THINK THEIR WORDS COULD BE SEEN
IN THE OFFENSE GIVEN THE RISKS
AT HAND. WITH ME TODAY IN
SUPPORT OUR FIRE CHIEF PEACH
PAGE MEYER OF THE SAN RAMON
VALLEY FIRE PROTECTION DISTRICT.
AND FIRE CHIEF DAVE WINOKUR OF
THE MORAGA ORINDA FIRE
PROTECTION DISTRICT. THEY'RE
BOTH ON THE PHONE. CAN YOU HEAR
ME THAT THE PAGE MYERS CONCERN
AMONG THOSE FIRE PROTECTION
DISTRICT. YES MR RICE ARE YOU
READY FOR THE FIRST WITNESS. YES
GO AHEAD YOU FIRE. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER A CHAIR GARCIA
VICE CHAIR PATTERSON- I'M PAIGE
MEYER FIRED SHE COULD BE SEVEN
DOLLARS FIVE PROTECTION DISTRICT
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
MAKE A FEW COMMENTS- I THINK THE
MOST IMPORTANT THING THAT I
WOULD KNOW. IN DISCUSSING BATES-
THIS BILL IS. AND WHICH DOES
YOUR DAD I AM WAS BROUGHT
FORWARD- TWELVE. A UTILITY W. TO
THE FIRE CHIEFS THAT WE WERE PUT
ON NOTICE ABOUT THREE YEARS AGO
THAT THE- UTILITY COMPANY WAS
GOING TO NEED TO START THEIR OWN
FIFTEEN EIGHTEEN WHICH IS ALSO A
FIRE TEAM AND WALDRON PUT ON
NOTICE AND THE FIRE CHIEF SAID
IN A BOOK THAT THEY WERE DOING
IT SO THAT WOULD BE SO
DANGEROUS. THAT THEY NEEDED
THEIR OWN FIREFIGHTERS IN OUR
JURISDICTION YOU CAN IMAGINE
WHAT THAT MADE US FEEL LIKE BY
NOT COMFORTABLE AT ALL THE DVD-
IN MY DISTRICT. IF SOMEONE MARC
MENTIONED YOU HAVE A SIR AREAS
IN ORDER. THAT ARE VERY VERY
HIGH FIRE RISK AREA. SO. FOR AND
- STARTED OUR OWN AND WORKED
WITH SOMEONE OF SOME MEMBER ON
THIS BILL. WHAT WE WANTED TO DO
WAS THAT CALL SAID AWARENESS I
KNOW WHEN HI WORK DANGEROUS WERE
AT THE- IF YOU STARTED HAVE A
FIRE YOU ON SCENE. THAT DAY
WOULD LEAD US KNOW AND THEN WE
COULD THE BECAUSE IT IS ARGUES.
WE FELT BETTER THAN ANYBODY.
BETTER THAN FOLKS IN OUR-
OFFICE. NO OUR OUR HOT SPOT IN
OUR IN OUR OF. WE COULD MAKE IT
LED TO DECISION TO KEEP. IN SAFE
. IT'S NOT TOO MUCH TO ASK AND-
WE THINK IT'S VERY. ESPECIALLY
GIVEN WHAT WE'VE SEEN OVER THE
LAST THREE YEARS BUT YOU'VE BEEN
DEVASTATING. PUT ON NOTICE IS
FIRE CHIEF I HAVE RESPONSIBILITY
TO MAKE SURE THAT I DO MY JOB
PLEASE ALLOW ME TO DO MY JOB
THANK YOU. THANK YOU CHIEF MARTY
FOR A CURRY ON THE LINE. YES
MA'AM GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE I'M DAVE ONE OCCUR
FAR KEEP THE ROCKERY TO FIRE
DISTRICT TIME TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY SEVENTY.
HIGH RISK ACTIVITY CREATE
CONDITION WHICH CAN SPREAD AND
THE SURROUNDING VEGETATION AND
OUR STRUCTURES MY TEAM IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE CONTROL TO
CHRISTIAN OF THE RESULTING FIRE.
UNDERSTANDING WHAT HIGH RISK
ACTIVITIES OCCURRING IN MY
DISTRICT SET CONDITIONS FOR THE
RAPID RESPONSE REQUIRED TO STOP
THE FIRE BEFORE IT SPREAD. IT'S
CRITICAL TO ACHIEVING POSITIVE
OUTCOMES IN MINIMISING FIRE
LOSS. FURTHER AFTER ARRIVING ON
SCENE IT TAKES TIME FOR THE
FIRST TWO UNITS TO MAKE. THE
CHAOTIC ENVIRONMENT WHICH
CHARACTERIZES THE EARLY STAGES
OF FIRE. THE MORE IS KNOWN ABOUT
THE SCENE PRIOR TO ARRIVAL THE
LEAD TIME IS REQUIRED TO
DETERMINE THE APPROPRIATE COURSE
OF ACTION. AND DEPLOY AVAILABLE
UNITS. UTILITY NOTIFICATION
PERMITS. SHARING THE- SUPPORT
EFFICIENT APPOINTMENT. A
FIREFIGHTING. BECAUSE THE PART
OPEN AND OPERATIONAL. ENABLE THE
TIME. BUYERS BEYOND. I
APPRECIATE THE OP SURE FENCED
AND- URGE THE COMMITTEE TO PASS
AB TWENTY TWO B. AS RICH THANK
YOU. I THINK WE GO TO THE PHONE
MODERATOR. UP NEXT- COMMENTS FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT I WOULD LIKE TO
PUBLIC COMMENT FIRST THEM AGO TO
THE MODERATOR- DO YOU HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN THE HEARING ROOM IN
SUPPORT OPPOSITION OR IN BETWEEN
- SESSION. OPPOSITION ONE WHAT
WE DO OPPOSITION FIRST OF ALL
RIGHT WELL. WHERE IS THAT WAS IT
A SCRIPT- THIS WORKERS HI. I TO
HEARING FROM NOW OPPOSITION YES
PRIMARY OPPOSITION PLEASE VISIT
BRANDY BACK WITH PGNIG- I THINK
JUST TO START TO SUM IT UP BUT
THIS IS WHAT WE VIEW AS A BILL
IN SEARCH OF A PROBLEM AS- THE
BILL IS A REDUCTION OF A BILL
THAT WAS NEVER HER LAST YEAR WE
HAVE BEEN ASKING THE AUTHOR
BONSER WORST. INSTANCES RELATED
TO ANY OF THE WORK THAT'S
DISCUSSED IN THIS BILL THAT HAS
BECAUSE IN ADDITION TO OUR
KNOWLEDGE THERE IS NONE. WE VIEW
AS LOCALLY- THAT WE THOUGHT WE
WERE NEGOTIATING WITH THE FIRE
DISTRICTS AND GET FACE TO
RESOLVE WE RESOLVE THOSE ISSUES
LOCALLY OVER THE FALL WE WERE
VERY SURPRISED TO SEE THAT THIS
BILL EVEN CAME BACK- IF THE
AMENDMENTS WERE TAKEN IN THE
ANALYSIS THAT ARE UP TO LIMIT
THE BILL JUST TWO PRESCRIBED
BURNS PROBABLY WOULD NOT BE HERE
TODAY BUT THAT. WAS DECLINED AND
THE BILLS NOW TAKE A DIFFERENT
DIRECTION. SEVERAL YOU'RE A
EXPLANATION OF WHY THIS BILL
WOULD JUST BE BURDENSOME AND- WE
HAVE TWO HUNDRED SIXTY THREE
DIFFERENT FIRE DISTRICTS IN OUR
SERVICE TERRITORY SOME WOULD
BENEFIT FROM THIS- NOTIFICATIONS
OF THE PASSPORT WE ARE HAPPY TO
HAVE TOSE DATES NEGOTIATIONS
WITH ANY OF OUR FIRE DISTRICTS.
BUT ALL THE ALL OKAY- BUT WE'VE
BEEN DOING HOT WORK FOR OVER A
HUNDRED YEARS WE DO HARD WORK
EVERY SINGLE DAY. THE WAY THE
BILLS THAT. YOU THAT DEFINITION.
IT'S OUR REGULAR ACTIVITIES THAT
OUR CREWS DO WITHOUT ANY
IGNITIONS THAT HAVE BEEN PROVEN-
WITH REGARD TO PRESCRIBERS WE-
DESCRIBE BURN SYSTEM AND- ASSIST
. OUR RESPONSIBILITY SO THAT
JUST IS NOT SOMETHING WE WOULD
HAVE TO DEAL WITH- AND THEN SIT
THERE IS THE STATE OF SAFETY
INSTRUCTOR PRODUCTION CREWS.
THOSE ARE- AN INNOVATIVE
SOLUTION THAT WE'VE COME UP WITH
THE LAST COUPLE YEARS WHERE WE
HAVE TRAINED OUR LEXICAL WORKERS
TO BE EVEN MORE PROFICIENT IN
FIREFIGHTING. TECHNOLOGY THAT'S
WHY THIS IS AT CORE LOCAL LABOR
ISSUE- THAT WE DON'T THINK IT'S
APPROPRIATE EXPANDER A STATEWIDE
MANDATE- WE USE THESE TO RISK
AND AGAIN THERE'S BEEN EMISSION
ASSOCIATE ARNIE'S CHRIS. WE
REALLY JUST. AFTER NO VOTE OR AT
LEAST ASK FOR THE BILL BE
AMENDED JUST TWO PRESCRIBED
BURNS. SOUTH MAKE YOU. TO ME TO
GO UP THERE ARE WOULD YOU PREFER
. OKAY REPUBLICAN. YEAH YES
SECOND PRIMARY OPPOSITION NEXT
PLEASE YEAH. THERE WE GO- GAP
INSURE MEMBERS ADAM SPECIFIC
CALIFORNIA'S IN OPPOSITION TO AB
TWENTY SEVENTY I AGREE WITH THE
COMMENTS FROM MY COLLEAGUE FROM
PG&E. THE REASONS WE WOULD- NO
VOTE ON THIS BILL RECENT ONE
WE'RE NOT REALLY CONVINCED THAT
THERE IS THE WORK IN QUESTION
POSES ANY RISK THE MEDIAN
HOUSES. LOOKED AT THE BILL AND
YOU KNOW LOOKED AT THE- AND NOT
BEEN A CLEAR INSTANCE WHERE THIS
HOT WORK. MENTIONED HAS SPARKED
UTILITY WILDFIRE. AND WE HAVEN'T
BEEN ABLE TO FIND ONE EITHER AT
THIS POINT REASON TO WE'RE NOT
SURE AND WE ARE HERE TO LOOK AT
TODAY AND ACTIONS IT IS. MORE IN
THE UNDERSTAND WHAT THE ARTIST
MIGHT DO WITH THIS WORK BECAUSE
IF THE- THE KIND OF WORK WITH-
SPARKED UP. IT'S NOT CLEAR TO
VALUE WE BRING TO THE FIRE
DISTRICTS IN THIS MAYBE GETS TO
THE POINT WE HEARD PETER PIGEON
ECOG TALK ABOUT IT THIS MIGHT
MORE LOCALIZED ISSUE BUT WE'RE
JUST NOT AWARE OF IN OUR SERVICE
TERRITORY HAVEN'T THIS THING.
MAYBE TO. GET WORK. SO WE'RE
OFFERING NOTIFICATIONS OF WHERE
WE'RE DOING WORK THERE'S OFTEN
TIMES WE HAVE TO MOBILIZE CREWS
TO EMERGENCIES OR OTHER THINGS
THAT WE THINK THIS COULD CREATE
A LOT OF PAPER TRANSFERRED TO
OUR DISTRICTS WE NOT HAVING
THESE. SORT OF RECALL. PRESS FOR
ARE FACTORED. WERE PRESSURE
HEADS WONDERING WHY WE NEED TO
KIND OF HAVE THIS BILL TO BE
TOTALLY HONEST. WE ALSO THINK
PAPER TRANSFER DOES RESULT IN
REPAIR COSTS YOU KNOW WE HAVE
EMPLOYEES WHO MAY NEED TO BE
DOING THESE NOTIFICATIONS
POTENTIALLY. NOTIFICATIONS AS
WERE CHANGES. BUT WRAP UP I
WOULD JUST SAY I MEAN IF THE
BILL TOOK THE AMENDMENTS TO MAKE
IS ABOUT. DATA WOULD NOT. IN
OPPOSITION TODAY WILL. THE
MINUTES YOU ARE TAKING A REALLY
APPRECIATE YOU DOING THAT AND
WE'LL LOOK AT IT WITH FRESH EYES
AND- AND COME BACK AROUND BUT
THAT'S HOW IS TODAY. THANK YOU.
OKAY- WILL NEXT MOVE TO THE A
PUBLIC COMMENT IN THE ROOM- IN
SUPPORT FIRST PLEASE. PUBLIC
COMMENT IN THE ROOM IN SUPPORT
PLEASE. I MET IN THE ROOM IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE. I KNOW
BETWEEN OURS. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHEN MEMBERS NIGGLING THAT AND
THEN AS WITH ANY- GAS AND
ELECTRIC IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU
FOR. AND IF XIN. MY TWITTER'S
BETTER GO TO THE CALIFORNIA
MUNICIPAL UTILITIES ASSOCIATION
NO POSITION TODAY WOULD LOOK FOR
TO REVIEWING THAT BILL WORKING
WITH THE AUTHOR AND THE SPONSORS
MAKE SURE WE INVEST A PLATFORM.
THANK. CONFIRM. ON THE PHONES
WE'RE GOING WE'RE GONNA GO THE
PHONE'S NEXT- FOR TO TESTIFY- IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION FOR AB
TWENTY SEVENTY- MISTER MODERATOR
PLEASE OPEN THE LINES AND MAKE
THE INVITATION FOR SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE. PETER AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH
TO COMMENT IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY SEVENTY
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AT THAT ZERO
AT THIS TIME. WHAT CAN YOU WISH
TO COMMENT IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION AB TWENTY SEVENTY.
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
ONE MOMENT FOR A FIRST COMICALLY.
I AM THIRTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON IS CALLING IN ON
BEHALF OF MARIN CLEAN ENERGY AND
SUPPORT. ONE MOMENT BIRD
EXPLAINED. IN FORTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS DR CAROL LEAD
I'M SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
DEMOCRATS ACROSS MORE AND MORE
ON THE CREEK WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL. NINE THIRTY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANKS THE HAVE THE HALF OF
THREE FIFTY BAY AREA ACTION
THREE FIFTY CONTRA COSTA ACTION
IN DEMOCRATS PROVIDES MORE TO
EXPRESS OUR STRONG SUPPORT. FOR
EIGHTY TWO ZERO SEVEN ZERO. WE
HAVE NO FURTHER LINES IN QUEUE
FOR AB TWENTY SEVENTY. I THANK
MODERATE WILL BRING THIS- BACK
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
MEMBERS NEVER QUIT YES- COULD BE
OPPOSITION COME UP AGAIN. I
DON'T KNOW WHAT HAPPENED TO THE
SECOND CHAIR. WE USUALLY HAVE
MORE ALL RIGHT- SO ARE YOU AWARE
OF THE AMENDMENT THAT THE AUTHOR
DID TANK. ON IN THIS AREA
THEY'RE CONCERNED ABOUT. WITH
RELATION TO GOD SHE DIDN'T TAKE
THE ONE IN THE ANALYSIS BUT YOU
DID TAKEN AMENDMENT ARE YOU
AWARE OF THAT. WE ARE AWARE OF
THE AMENDMENT THAT WOULD PRO. MR
FROM US FOR THE LAST RIDERSHIP
DATA. BUT IT WOULD STILL WORK US
TO GO THROUGH. A SERIES OF
MEDICATION TO ALL TWO HUNDRED
SIXTY THREE FAR DISTRICTS FOR
OUR VERY VERY REGULAR HOTWORK
AND HOPE FOR SINCE MOST FIRE
DISTRICTS ISSUE SAID. CARE I'M
I'M WONDERING IF YOU IN THE
AUTHOR COULD AGREE ON IF THE
FIRE DISTRICT WANTS TO BE
NOTIFIED. THAT BOB SHE WILL FIVE
THEM BUT ONLY IF THEY ASK FOR
IT. JUST SUGGESTING THAT DON'T
EXPECT ANYONE TO SEE YES OR NO.
BUT I THINK THAT MIGHT WORK
THINGS OUT. WE'LL SEE. YEAH I
MEAN WE'RE HAPPY TO LOOK AT THAT
THAT'S BEEN OUR PERSPECTIVE IS
THAT ANY FIRE DISTRICT IS
WELCOME TO DISCUSS ANY ISSUES
WITH US RELATED COMMUNICATION OR
CAREERS WHICH TO OUR KNOWLEDGE
ONLY TO SERVE OUR AUTHORS
DISTRICT. BROUGHT BURKE AND PAT
THIS IS A FOR LATER THIS WEEK ON
BOTH ORDER SAYS AND NONE OF
OTHER. TWO HUNDRED SIXTY ONE
PART OF ASSETS SO THAT'S THE
POINT THE POINT IS IF SHE
LIMITED THE BILL IN THAT WAY AND
AGAIN NOT ASKING FOR YES OR NOT.
FROM THE TIME. THAT WORKS.
YOU'RE GOING. I MEAN IF THE
DISTRICT REALLY WANTED GONNA
TELL. FOR AND- JUST SAY. SO I
THINK SOMETHING CAN BE WORKED
OUT OF THE VOTING NIGHT TODAY
AND ON THIS BILL MOVED YET. NOT
YET WE STILL HAVE OTHER
QUESTIONS COMMENTS ABOUT YOUR
MOVE IT SOME OF IT. IS OUR
SECOND. RESPECT SECOND OTHER
COMMENTS QUESTIONS BY MEMBERS.
HOLDEN JUST A COMMA- THE SAID
NEXT YEAR I PROBABLY WOULD HAVE
FORGOT ABOUT IT- WHOSE- SO I
HAVE A POSITION ON THE BILL
ALREADY- I'M NOT GOING TO VOTE
AGAINST THE BILL BECAUSE IT
SOUNDS LIKE THERE'S AMENDMENTS
THAT ARE STILL THAT ARE THAT
YOU'RE ON AND THEN PROBABLY
SHOULDN'T HAVE MIGHTY OFF FROM
THERE. RESERVE MY THOUGHTS- BUT-
BUT I DO APPRECIATE THE FACT
THAT IT SOUNDS LIKE YOU'VE MADE
SOME CONCESSIONS SINCE LAST YEAR
. IT AM INTERESTED MESSAGES
PLEASE. DO SO THE AUTHOR MS
BARAKAT INDICATED THAT IT'S JUST
A MATTER OF A PHONE CALL OR AN
EMAIL ME WHY NOT HAVE TWO
HUNDRED WHATEVER FIRE DISTRICTS
EMAILS. JUST STOP NOTICE WE'RE
DOING FIREWORK ON THIS DAY OR
THERE'S ALSO A FIVE DOLLARS
CIVIL FINE FOR EVERY FAILURE IS
NOT AN IT FOR A TYPE OF. WORK
THAT THIS NOT BE APPROPRIATE. I
DON'T KNOW IF. GET PAID LIKE
DETERMINE AS WELL. HOW HOW
FREQUENTLY IS JUST TYPE OF HOT
WORK DONE THE THAT THE IS
WRITTEN IN THE- IT'S VERY
UNCLEAR WHY THAT SPECIFIC
DEFINITION EVEN CREATES FIRE
RISK ALL IT SPEAKS TO IS WORK
DONE WITH ANY TYPE OF
INSTRUMENTS THAT MIGHT CREATE A
SPARK ON LINES THAT WERE WORKING
ON OVER FIFTEEN VOTE. PUT IN
THERE BY DIFFERENT OF SO IT'S WE
TO BASICALLY COME UP WITH A NEW
PROTOCOL TO USE A NEW DEFINITION
OF WE DON'T CURRENTLY EMPLOYED
THERE ARE SPECIFIC HOT WORK.
RECALL THAT WE DEAL WITH WITH L.
AS THOUGH IT'S A DIFFERENT THAT
IN THE NOTES SEPT. GET IT AB.
COME A NOTIFICATION BAR. FOR
EVERY STEP AND- YOU WE MIGHT
DOING CON DIFFERENT CIRCUITS
COVER MULTIPLE DIFFERENT
PARTITIONS IN A SINGLE DAY SO-
WE- BECAUSE HAVE TO REARRANGE
OUR CREWS WHEN WE HAD A LOT OF
THE- STORM OUTAGES IN JANUARY. A
LOT OF OUR PLANNED WORK WAS THAT
SUDDENLY- CHANGED AND WE'RE
GETTING QUESTIONS FROM A LOT
MEMBERS ABOUT WHEN CERTAIN.
WORKERS SIR NEIGHBORHOODS SO
THERE'S LOT TO GO INTO
COORDINATOR OUR ASSETS AND ANY
ADDITIONAL PAIRS OF THAT DO YOU
JUST INCREASE OUR- COSTS TO
COMPLY TEACHER. THE QUESTION FOR
THE AUTHOR UGH- THE SAID THE
CANADIAN ELSE'S DOES SAY THAT
THERE IS NO DOCUMENTED EVIDENCE
OF FIREWORK HOT WORK THE CAUSING
A- FIRE. BY NASSER THIRTY REST A
COUPLE THINGS THAT HAVE COME UP
THAT I'M NOT AN OPPORTUNITY
DRESS WHICH IS- THANK YOU MISTER
BURKE FOR. I'M AT ONE OF THE
REASONS DOING THIS BILL IS ANY
CLAIMS OF THE EASY FOR HER TO
HOLD ON I WANNA BE A 100% CLEAR
THEY SUED. THESE DISTRICTS WENT
TO COURT AND MY FIRE CHIEF WHOSE
JOB IS TO KEEP MY COMMUNITY SAFE
WITH SPENDING HIS TIME
LITIGATING THIS. SO THAT IS WHY
WE NEED TO DO THIS BECAUSE FOR
EVERYONE OF THESE FIRE DISTRICTS
IN HIGH FIRE ZONE TO GO TO COURT
AND YOU NEED TO GET NOTICES WERE
. US TO PUT HER AT. SAYING MAY
BE NOT BIG NOTICE I WENT TO
COURT IT I'M SECONDLY I WOULD
SAY THE HOT WORKED UP IT'S TO
THEN USE NINE TIMES AND CODE
IT'S STANDARD. IF PG&E WANTS TO
TALK TO US OR AT OUR CENTER THE
OTHER I USE I SHOULD SAY YOU'RE
NOT GONNA SITTING RIGHT CAMP I.
HAPPY TO HAVE THAT CONVERSATION
BUT THAT ISN'T RECESSION THEY'RE
JUST TRYING TO KILL THE BILL-
REQUEST AND I ASK MY FIRED ON
THIS IS A CRITICAL BECAUSE I
KNOW THE AND THAT IS WHY THEY
STARTED THIS EFFORT IS BIG THEY
SEE THE IS IT.
WHY NOT. THIS IS LIMITED TO HIGH
FIRE ZONES. SO THIS ISN'T YOU
KNOW YOU'RE URBAN ENVIRONMENT
WHERE YOU DON'T HAVE TO WORRY
ABOUT THIS THESE ARE THE
COMMUNITIES WERE IF THE SPARK
FLIES ON A WINDY DAY WE HAVE A
REAL REAL. CONCERN AT CHIEF
MEYER. UNITS RESPOND TO THE
MEMBER'S QUESTION. YET YEAH
THAT'S A GOOD POINT IF HIGH FIRE
RISK AREAS KEEP IN MIND. DON'T
LET ANYBODY TELL YOU THAT WE
NEED TO KNOW EVERY SINGLE THING
THEY DID THEY'RE DOING THAT'S
JUST NOT TRUE. THAT'S NOT TRUE
THE BILL NOT NOT SHOULD WITHOUT
. YEAH SO THIS. NOBODY BUYERS
WILL BE SPARKED INTO BEEN
INVESTING. THAT I HIGH LEVEL. SO
I WOULD LIKE. THE IRONY THAT I
FONG. IT COMMERCENTRE ABOUT A
WOULD BE. NOTICE YEAH. ONCE I
FIND IT ALSO KIND OF TO GIVE TO
REDUCE. YEP MAY HAVE A CITY CODE
OF THE TO THE FIGHTS. THE BILL'S
LEAD ON. LET'S CUT THEM IF IT'S
NOT AN ISSUE WHY AM I BEING TOO.
BY JURORS FIRE ENGINES ARE GOING
TO BE A LOT. WITH DANGEROUS WORK. I'M NOT A KNOW IF THERE IF
THEY WANT PUT THEIR MY WHERE
THEIR MOUTH IS AND WHETHER THE
MOVE DOES THOSE AFTER. YEAH
ABSENT HARD WORK WINDOWS HIGH
FIRE RATE AREAS. THE IS NO
DOCUMENTED. THEN WHY ARE THEY
THERE THAT LIKE A PROP SO TO PUT
COMMITTEES I GONNA GO WITH WHAT
THE ACTUAL VOTER ID SPEAKS THAN
WHAT THEY'RE SAYING THANK YOU.
I'M MISTER IF YOU WANT TO
COMMENT ON SOMETHING. CAME TO
THE MICROPHONE. MEMBER CAREER
THEN M. THEN MEMBER MAY MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS GOT WHICH ON
BEHALF OF THE CAL CODE IF YOU
EMPLOY IN PLAN SPEAKING ON BILL
TODAY. WE HAVE NOT TAKEN OF
POSITION BUT WANT TO A LITTLE.
POLICE FIFTEEN THOUSAND. A DAY.
DOING HOT WORK WE DON'T DE
ENERGIZED LINES. VERY RARELY DO
WE DE ENERGIZED LINES THIS
HAPPENS EVERY DAY. ACROSS THE
ENTIRE STATE. I CAN'T IMAGINE IT
IF THE UTILITIES ARE CALLING THE
FIRE DEPARTMENT THEY'RE GONNA
HAVE AN ENGINE CREW AT THE READY
TO GO AND RESPOND. OUR CREWS ARE
TWO TO THREE MEMBER CREWS. EVERY
MEMBER CARRIES A MIRACULOUS
DEVICE IT'S CALLED SOFA. AND IF
A FIRE WERE TO BE SPARKED THEY
WOULD CALL NINE ONE ONE. I CAN'T
IMAGINE THAT THAT PROCESS IS
GOING TO BE ANY SLOWER THAN IF
THE FIRE DEPARTMENT SOMEWHERE IN
THE DISTANCE WHAT'S CALLED A DAY
OR TWO EARLIER. SEVEN MEMBER
CARILLO OKAY. AND THEN- MEMBER
MAYES AND THEN- MEMORIES. I JUST
I'M JUST SORT OF OTHER ACTUALLY
PROVIDED SOME- SOME HELP TO ALL
THIS BECAUSE ON ITS FACE
PROVIDING AN EMAIL OR
TRANSPARENCY SEEMS LIKE IT'S NO
NO BIG DEAL- ALSO THE FACT
THERE'S SUCH CONSTERNATION BY.
THE CHILI'S ALSO A LITTLE ODD TO
ME SO I'M TRYING TO REALLY
FIGURE IT OUT I'VE BEEN- GAL TO
THE FORMER MANY HERE A LITTLE
BETTER IT IS OLD. HERE HE IS
THAT HE- BE. ARE POSSIBLE THIS
BILL. AND I. GUESS GOOD REASON.
WHY MAYBE IT'S THE COMMENTS THAT
THAT MR WHY HAD JUST SAID BUT I
DON'T KNOW IF YOU WANT TO-
TALKING OR- A PUT YOU ON THE
SPOT. I'M A GIVE TIME THREE. THE
TIME FRANKLY TRIED FIGURE THIS
THIS THIS BILL THIS BILL OUT
BECAUSE AGAIN ON ITS FACE IT
DOESN'T SEEM THAT BIG OF A DEAL
AND IT AT THE SAME TIME- IT DOES
LIKE YOU COULD ACTUALLY CREATE.
A MORE MORE FARM AS WELL- I'M-
JUST STRUGGLING A LITTLE BIT
LESS MATT. THIS RESTAURANT
RESEARCHERS YES. YES. THROUGH
THE CHAIR- I JUST WANT TO ONE OF
THE THINGS WE HEARD LAST YEAR-
ON THIS BILL WITH THIS WOULD BE
TOO COMPLICATED AND TOO
DIFFICULT AND I'M I SORT OF TRY
TO WRAP MY HEAD THE SAME WAY YOU
DO BECAUSE HIS CREW. STRETCHES
AS THEM IS TELLING THEIR CURSE
WHERE TO GO AND WHAT TO DO RIGHT
I DON'T KNOW IF THAT MECHANISM
IS I NEVER GOT AN ANSWER I DID
ASK THAT QUESTION- IT. PART OF
HER. AGAIN SEEM. A LITTLE BIT
CONFUSING TO ME IN EVERY
SITUATION WITH THE FIRE CHIEF
SENT A FIRE CREW MADE WE COULD
LET THE FIRE CHIEF SANTA THAT
BUT MY GUESS IS NO BUT I CAN'T
SAY THAT WHEN. BECAUSE IT IS
EASY TO LOCATE WHERE THE WORK IS
BEING DONE IS SIGNIFICANT IT'S
REMOTE OFTEN IN THE COMMUNITIES
THAT I REPRESENT YOU HAVE. HARD
EVACUATION ROUTES IN SOME OF
THESE WHERE I LIVE. ONE WORD IN
ONE ROW OUT. CHIEF WINOKUR. I
HEARD ALL GETTING OUT TO. MEDIA
WINDY TODAY THANK FIRE STAND
THIS WORK IS BEING DONE AND THE
COMMUNITY IS ALL AT HOME AT THAT
TIME WHAT HE SAID OF OUR GROUP
PROBABLY RIGHT SO DEPEND THEY
MAKE THAT JIM BUT IN THE
INFORMATION TO MAKE DECISIONS.
WE WHEN WE SEEN IN THE- IT. OUT
ALL UTILITY. WILDFIRES THERE
WHEN FIRE CREWS CAN THEIR TO
FASHION IT HAPPEN MY DISTRICT
MANY TIME WE CAN GO A HELOC. ON
A GROUNDER CHRONIC. THEY CAN
STOP THE HERE'S EIGHT. THAT'S
ALL WE'RE LOOKING FOR. IT IF I
IF I CAN'T. MISTER CHAIR BECAUSE
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT THIS THAT
SORT OF CAME TO MY MIND IS IF
YOU DO PROVIDE THESE NOTICES
THAT THERE'S FIFTEEN THOUSAND
THE FIRED UP. IS GONNA GET GET
THE- EVERY SINGLE DAY AND THEN
IT BECOMES NO BIG DEAL TO THEM
THAT'S GOING TO BE EVERY SINGLE
DAY. EIGHT SO THE TEN
CONSEQUENCES THAT ARE THAT ARE
THERE AND THEN I GUESS THE OTHER
THING I'M SORT OF MAYBE MISSING
AS WELL IS THAT IF THERE ISN'T
ANY PARTICULAR INSTANCE OF A
STAR AT THE- STOP BY PER SOME
SOME NOTICE MAKES IN A WAY.
MAYBE THAT THERE IS IN SEARCH OF
A TRYING TO SOLVE SOMETHING
MAYBE ISN'T YET UP BUT YET A
PROBLEM I'M SO CAN YOU PROVIDE
THAT INSTANCE OF AND- I. A LINE
THEY'RE ALREADY GETTING THESE
THE TWO CHIEFS HEARD FROM SO I
THINK THEY'RE GONNA YOUR ABOUT
THE NUMBER GET IT TOO MANY SORT
IN WHICH ONE TO DRESS BEFORE IF
YOU WANT TO PASS THAT THE AS
WELL. YOU SHOULD. NUMBER THAT
WILL BE A TO RECEIVE AND PROCESS
I'LL TELL YOU I WOULD MUCH
RATHER HAVE THE INFORMATION
REGARDING HIGH RISK GROUP THE
POINT OF RESOURCES IN MY
DISTRICT THAT THAT'S A PROBLEM
WE CAN SOLVE BORN TURN. IF THAT
THAT. THE TRIGGER THAT REQUIRE
NOTIFICATION ARE NOT NEARLY AS
MANY HITS AS HAVE BEEN
PREVIOUSLY CITED IN THAT
TESTIMONY TODAY. THE BILL NUMBER
AND ALLOWS US. SOME PICTURE OF
WHAT BY RESTRICTIVE VISA DURING
WITHIN OUR DISTRICT AND ALLOWS
US TO UTILIZE THAT AS PART OF
THE PLANNING CONSIDERATION THEY
GO INTO THE POT OUR RESOURCES ON
THE BASIS SO IT THE IN. NORTH
MUCH INFORMATION AND THEN
SURPRISED LEARN THE THESE THINGS
ARE AND ONLY THE WORK BECAUSE OF
THE COMMISSION. THE PRESENCE OF
FIREFIGHTING REESE. THIS SO CAN
UNIPER OF OUR FIGHT DISTRICT
APART UNIT OR ON. DISCOVERED
THAT MOST OF THE OTHER FIRE FOR
YOU. FROM UP. THE PROVIDER
ALREADY THERE THAT DELAY HERE
FOR BUT EVERY TO SAYS CA. THAT
IN. THE ANSWER IN THE DYNAMIC.
ARE THE- THIRTEEN FIREFIGHTER
RESPONSE. AND SHARING THE
INFORMATION. HELPS US FORM A
COMMON OPERATING PICTURE ARE
RAPIDLY LEADS A MORE EFFICIENT.
PUBLIC TO RESOURCES ALLOWS US TO
STOP FIRE BOOTH SPREAD UNDER ANY
. AND THEN MISS I'M SORRY FOR I
CAN ASSIST YOU FURTHER A AND
THEN IS TO YOUR ALREADY GETTING
THESE NO A- THEN. YOU'RE ALREADY
RIGHT IN THE ORDINANCE. CORRECT
BY ORDINANCE THE MACARENA FIRE
DISTRICT REQUIRES NOTIFICATION
FOR SIPG TEAM DEPLOYMENTS- AND
THE HARD WORK THAT REQUIRES SIPG
DEPLOYMENT- WE WERE SUED HAVING
PASSED THAT ORDINANCE WITH P.
GENIE WITHDREW. OF THIS RACE AND. INITIALLY WHEN I SPOKE WITH
THE AUTHOR ABOUT MY CONCERN DO
WITH DUPLICATE NOTICES. BUT I AM
ALSO A QUANDARY LIKE- MY
COLLEAGUE. IT SEEMS THEM AS THIS
BILL MOVES FORWARD SHOULD IT.
MOVE FORWARD IS DEFINING THE NON
EMERGENCY HOT WORK SO THAT IT
ISN'T OWNERS SO THAT IT THERE
ARE. THERE IS A DEFINITION OF
WHAT IT WILL. REQUIRE THEM TO
NOTICE TO GO TO THE FIRE CHIEFS
OR TO THE FIRE FIRE DISTRICTS OF
THE FACT THAT IT'S JUST FOR A
HARD FOUGHT BUT AREAS ALSO IS
GOING TO REDUCE THE NUMBER OF.
SIX THAT ARE BEING DONE. REQUIRE
THE NOTICE. OF THE TWO HUNDRED
AND FIFTY THREE FIRE DISTRICTS I
DON'T KNOW IF THAT REFERS TO.
ALL OF CALIFORNIA OR JUST THE
HIGH FIRE THREAT AREAS. THAT
SPECIFIC TO OUR SERVICE
TERRITORY WITHOUT HIGH
FIREFIGHTERS AT ALL I THINK. OF
WHICH I'M NOT SURE I'D HAVE TO
LOOK AT OVERLAP WE HAVE AS
DISCUSSED PREVIOUSLY WE HAVE
OVER THREE THOUSAND MILES OF
TRANSMISSION LINES IN HIGH FIRE
AFFAIRS WE HAVE OVER TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND MILES OF. DISTRIBUTION
LINES HIGH FURTHER TERRITORIES.
THIS BILL JUST SAYS FIVE OUR
THIRD DISTRICT DOESN'T SAVE
TIMES OF THE YEAR OR BY SHE'S
THIS THE- BEST DIFFERENT THAT
BORDER. WHETHER BACK TO THE
LOCAL ORDINANCE WE SEE BECAUSE-
THE OFFICE SAID THAT WE HAD TO
PAY FIRED FOR THE CALL TO DEPLOY
OUR TROOPS. ARE LARGER CIRCLE.
MAY IT WAS IT'S BEEN SAID THAT
WE HAVE FOR TRUCKS AROUND WE
DON'T. ACCEPT DO NOT GOING FAR
TRUCKS THERE. A WORKER THAT HAVE
FIRE FIVE SKILLS. AND IF A FIVE
IGNITES WE ARE REQUIRED. TO CALL
THE FIRE DEPARTMENT. SO THEY
WILL BE NOTIFIED IN THAT
INSTANCE WE HAVE VERY CLEAR
REQUIREMENTS ABOUT OUR USE OF
THESE. CREWS IN OUR WATER
MITIGATION PLAN IT COVERS OVER
TWENTY PAGES I BELIEVE ABOUT
WHEN AND WHERE AND WHY WE USE
THESE CRITTERS. THERE'S TO.
TWENTY PERSON CREWS CURRENTLY
THAT WE- THAT WE HAVE THAT ARE
TRAINED TO DO THIS TYPE OF WORK.
AGAIN IT'S TO REDUCE RISK IT'S-
IN OUR WITH. OUR WATER
MITIGATION PLANS COVER OVER I
BELIEVE SEVEN HOT. WHAT WE ARE.
THIS WORK IS WITHOUT INSTANCES
OF- FIRES BEING IGNITED IT SEEMS
COUNTERINTUITIVE TO REGULATE OUR
USE OF THESE CAREERS THAT ARE
THERE TO REDUCE RISK INTO LOWER
VEGETATION AND TO. CUT OUT ANY
ADDITIONAL FIRES I COULD SPEAK
AGAIN WOULD NOT REALLY CLEAR
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO SOLVE IT. I
THINK I WANT TO GO BACK TO WHAT
MADE BY MY COLLEAGUE. DR QUIRK.
THAT IF. A FIRE DISTRICT SAYS
GIVE US THE NOTICE THEM TO
FIGURE OUT A WAY TO GIVE THEM
THE NOTICE THAT ISN'T WITH THE
BILL SAYS BUT- THE END OF. IF
YOUR DISTRICT WANT IT AND IT
TOOK AWHILE TO GET IT THEN MAYBE
SOMETHING NEEDS TO BE DONE SO
THAT- THE FIRE DISTRICTS DON'T
HAVE TO GO THROUGH ALL THROUGH
LIVE. TO WITH THE FIRE JUST
DOESN'T WANT IT THEN CLEARLY YOU
WOULDN'T HAVE TO PROVIDE IT. BUT
IT TO GIVE THAT OPTION TO THE
FIRE DISTRICT IT'S A DIFFICULT
ONE I AM GOING TO GIVE A
COURTESY- I VOTE. AND SEE HOW
HOW THIS. PROCEEDS TO FIGURE OUT
IF INDEED IT IS. A SOLUTION
LOOKING FOR A PROBLEM. BUT I
WILL TELL YOU THAT THE TESTIMONY
OF THE FIRE CHIEF MAKES. A BIG
DIFFERENCE IN THIS BECAUSE IT IS
A LIFE EXPERIENCE AND WITH THE
WILD FIRES WE HAD. THE LAST
THING WE WANT IS TO CUT CORNERS
AND NOT TAKE CARE OF SOMETHING
THAT POTENTIALLY COULD CAUSE
SERIOUS. PROBLEMS AND LOSS OF
LIFE AND PROPERTY. SO I HAVE A
QUESTION AND THEN PROBABLY
ANOTHER FOLLOW UP QUESTION ON
THE ON THE CIVIL PENALTY PIECE.
IS THE PENALTY ASSESSED THE
FAILURE TO PROVIDE THE WRECKED
QUIZ THAT NOTICE IS IT A PER
OCCURRENCE TYPE PENALTY. THE
EXACT CORRECT YES FOR EVERY
NOTED FAILURE TO NOTIFY OKAY SO
. I'M TRYING TO WEIGH THE COST
BENEFIT ON THAT BECAUSE- IT
SEEMS LIKE. ANOTHER WAY TO GET
UP ON A TRENARY RAGE FILLED BUT
I MEAN ANOTHER WAY TO GO WOULD
BE YOU KNOW THERE'S A CIVIL
PENALTY THE NOTE REQUIRED
CONSENT AND THEIR SON
DEMONSTRABLE HARM THE RESULTS
AND THEN THE PENALTY MAYBE IS
HIGHER. BUT THE MY CONCERN PANEL
THING THE- S. THE LACK VIæT
NOTICED THE BOARD- THE INCENTIVE
FOR THE UTILITIES IS JUST TO
JUST BE BLANKETING EVERYBODY IN
ASSISTIVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAYES
POINT AND- ALSO THE- ADDRESSES
POINT I MEAN THERE'S SORT OF
THIS INCENTIVE CREATED UNDER
THIS BILL TO. BE COVERING YOUR
REAR. THIS IS CONSTANTLY AND
THEN I WONDER WHAT. THE YOU KNOW
IS THERE A DAY LUCIA FACT I MEAN
IT'S BUT ARE THEY JUST GOING TO
BE. FILED WHEN PEOPLE GET THEM
WHEN MAY IT MAYBE IT COULD BE
NARROWED SO THAT. THERE'S
LIABILITY THAT'S MAYBE HIGHER
BUT I'M SURE THE UTILITIES WOULD
LOVE THAT YEAH BUT THE IF THERE
THEY SHOULD HAVE PROVIDED THE
NOTICE UNDER CERTAIN SAID
PRESCRIBED CIRCUMSTANCES AND
THEY DIDN'T AND THERE'S SOME
HARM THAT RESULTS FROM THAT
NOTICE ON JUST. WONDER THAT IT
SEEMS LIKE A- ME BECAUSE I. HAD
TO DO THE BILL HYATT IN BUT I AM
ALSO HE- THAT THE UTILITY
WORKERS ARE. IN THE TWO BE
SAYING. WE HAVE AN REALLY HAD A
PROBLEM WITH THIS BEFORE SO- I
I'M JUST OPENING UP TO ANY
COMMENTS FROM SUPPORT OPPOSITION
IN RESPONSE TO. MY RAMBLING IT
WAS A RANDOMLY THANK YOU MISTER
CUNNINGHAM- I'LL START WITH JUST
POINTING OUT TO EVERYBODY HERE
THAT BOTH THE FIRE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION THE CALIFORNIA MARCH
DECISION AND THE FIRE DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. SO I THINK
. THIS RACES POINT YOU KNOW
THERE DISTRICTS OUT THERE THE
WANTED I'M EVERY BIT I WANT TO
BE CLEAR I'M OPEN TO A BOTH. S.
AT WHICH- IN THE- ADDITION TO
THE TOP COST THESE DISTRICTS TO
GET THERE I'M FOR THIS NOTICE OF
DISTRICT DOESN'T WANT IT YOU'RE
RIGHT I DON'T SEE THEY WOULDN'T
USE IT LIKELY RIGHT SO WHAT'S
THE POINT SOME ABSOLUTE OPEN TO
HAVING THAT CONVERSATION IN
GETTING THEIR FOR- THAT PIECE OF
IT BUT- AND I DO WANT TO GO TO
CHIEF MEYER ON THE RISK BECAUSE
I THINK IT'S REAL- BUT I DO WANT
TO JUST POINT OUT MISTER
CUNNINGHAM THAT AYE. I THINK
IT'S REALLY COOL WE DON'T ALWAYS
WAIT UNTIL WE'VE LOST HOMES AND
LIVES TO DO SOMETHING RIGHT AND
I THINK THAT'S WHAT THESE FIRE
CHIEFS ARE TRYING TO DO THEIR TO
SET A TRIAL TO SEE A COMMUTE
FRONT END RIGHT AND IF YOU DO
THAT LET DO THAT LET'S THIS
NOTICE. YEAH IS IT. SOUNDS LIKE
FROM THE CHIEFS. BECAUSE THERE
ARE THESE TWO ARE. AND THAT ARE
GOING CITIZENS. ONEROUS IT IS
NOT A LOT OF NOTED. THAT DOES
NOT QUANTIFY THE WAY WE'VE BEEN
HEARING FROM THE OPPOSITION- BUT
I DO THINK IT'S IMPORTANT WE TRY
TO DO SOMETHING ON THE FRONT TO
PREVENT THESE FIRES. I DO THINK
THAT IS A CRITICAL STEP THIS
LEGISLATURE SHOULD BE TAKING BUT
I'M- A LAST YOU'VE MEYER HE
WANTS TO ADD ANYTHING ON THE
RISK RETURN TO PREVENT. BUT YET.
THANK YOU SO REMEMBER THE ONLY
THING. THE ONLY. COUPLE OF
NUMBER ONE- HAVE THAT FIRE
STARTED. IN EIGHTY SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS- FROM HOT WORK. WE HAVE
BEEN CALLED OUT. AFTER THE FACT
BY A CITIZEN WITH AN EXPLOSION.
IN A TRANSFORMER. SO IT DOES
HAPPEN. SO THIS IDEA THAT IT'S
NEVER HAPPENED. IT'S JUST THAT I
THINK THAT THE- NO- COMMITTEE
SMART ENOUGH TO KNOW THAT THAT'S
JUST NOT TRUE. AND HE ALSO SMART
ENOUGH TO KNOW THAT. YEAH THEY
DO HAVE THE STATE. WHICH ARE. I
TOLD HIM SETTING THE THEIR JOB.
YOU KNOW BETTER. YOU KNOW MY-
ELECTRICITY STE WHICH I HAVE A
KIND OF START FOR. THAT'S NOT
WHAT SAYING. WHAT WE SEE DID
THIS. TYPE OF THE- TYPES ENGINES
THAT WE USE ON OUR STAY FIRED.
SO I DON'T HAVE ANY TYPE OF TYPE
CIKK THE HI THE NUMBER STATE OF
THE CIRCLE. AND THEY HAVE SAME
THING WE UTILIZE IN ITS SINCE.
THE FIRE IN THEY'RE NOT IT MAY
BE ONE OF THEM INTO BUT THEY'RE
NOT TO TRUCK THE- IS WHAT DIDN'T
. AN EXTRA SO HAVEN'T THEM YEAH
AND IT HAS. IT OUR IN OUR AREA
AND I AND I DO UNDER. HE. BUT I
WANT TO BE THE STOCK. THE FACT
THAT. IT'S.
HAPPEN I THINK THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING TO SAY INCLUDING
THE VICTIMS HAVE NOT BEEN
ORDERED THAT ALL. KIND OF FACT.
GET NOTIFIED BECAUSE IT IS ONLY
IN HIGH FIRE RISK AREAS IT'S NOT
WE DON'T EVEN KNOW. EVERYTHING
THEY DO WE ONLY NEED TO. IN HIGH
FIRE RISK AREAS AND IT IS V. AT
BEST- AND I GOOD MY COLLEAGUES
MEDICAL ON THAT SO I'M- BUT CAN
. I'M HERE WITH. BIG DEAL. I'M
NOT SAYING IT AND I HAVE MORE
THAN A SO I'M COMPETITION THERE
SO- I'M NOT WITH RESPECT TO WHAT
THAT CHANGE SOMETHING IN NO
LONGER USE BUT FAULT OF INTO THE
FOR THAT JUST BOUGHT WITHIN THE
LAST YEAR WHICH ARE VERY
EXPENSIVE. HIRING PEOPLE THE
HIGHLY. AND HIGHLY TRAINED TO.
ON AND FIRE MITIGATION. AND I'M
NOT SPENT SOME SO THAT MIGHT
COME THANK. IF WITH CHAIRS AND
SO SOME OTHER. WAS IT. OKAY SO
PROVIDING THE NOTICE AND A HIGH
RATE OF HIGH FIRE AREA. PROVIDE
SOME PREVENTIVE BECAUSE I THINK
ALL ANGRY WITH YOU WOULD RATHER
NOT START FIRES AND CLEAN UP THE
MESS AFTERWARDS- YOUR WHAT WHAT. HOW DOES THAT'LL ALLOW THE
FIRE DEPARTMENT WHAT DO THEY DO
WITH THAT INFORMATION LIKE ARE
THEY THEY PUT TRUCKS AT THE
READY OR DO THEY LIKE REAL
PEOPLE OUT STAND AROUND WATCHING
WHAT PEOPLE ARE DOING THEIR
UTILITY WORK IN THE IF YOU KNOW
SECOND HOSE OFF ANY SPARKS- A- I
UNDERSTAND. WHO IS- WHAT'S YOUR
RESPONSE TO THE ISSUE RAISED
ABOUT CONFLICTING ORDINANCES
WITH THIS POTENTIAL LAW BECAUSE
THAT SEEMS LIKE SOMETHING THAT
NEEDS TO BE IRONED OUT IS THAT
IS THIS LAW DOES IT OVERRIDE ANY
ORDINANCES ARE THEY REQUIRED TO
GIVE IT ONE ANSWER HOW MANY ARE
DISTRICT IS OF AN INCIDENT
BECAUSE THE SLOPE IT SEEMS LIKE
YOU WANT THE CLEANEST MOST
STREAMLINED THING POSSIBLE
ISSUES RIGHT THROUGH IT HER
DROPS. WHERE WERE YOU JUST YOU
DO WITHIN. THAT WOULD BE FOR
HERE FROM YOU. YES I AGREE THAT
HAVE AND I'LL GIVE GUYS KIND OF
. YEAH OPEN STILL FIRE THINK BY
MY SOMEBODY EARLIER I HAVE THE
WAY SIDE OF MY DISTRICT LEADER
GILLES NOT THE SAME LEVEL OR OR
SCOPE OF. THE OPEN HELD BUT-
LIMITED ACCESS IN LIMITED THAT.
AND THE FIRE A AND THAT MIX WITH
GOT MY COULD BEEN IF I DIDN'T
KNOW TO PUT EIGHT EIGHT WORK OUR
A HOT WILL BE DONE DURING OUR
WILD SEE THEN WE KNOW SEND THE
OUT JUST LOOK AT THE AREA NOT TO
NOT. WHAT THE BILL IS DOING BUT
THIS WHAT THE- ARE WORTHY OF
SPACE ARE GIVEN I CALLED
SITUATION AWARENESS KIND OF THE
NUMBER ONE WORLD BY. KNOWING
WHAT TOP BECAUSE I KNOW YOU CAN
PICK UP A SELF AND CALL I GOT
BUT WHEN WE GET A CELL PHONE
CALL WE DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT IS
WE HAVE NO BIG ROLE WE HAVE THE-
THOUGHT PROCESS YEP GO BACK AND-
SO. NO GLOBAL ARE. CONCERNS UP
WAY RIGHT YOU HEAR THE BALL TO
THE- I'M DOING A QUICK QUICK
LOOK AT THE WORK BEING DONE AWAY
BEING DONE AS SAY NOTHING WHAT
THE WEIRD THING. AND THEN WHEN
THE CALL COMES IN WE'LL LET YOU
GO. THEY HAVE TAKEN A CELL PHONE
CALL. TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHERE
TO PUT CRIMINAL THE OTHER END.
BUT ANY IDEA WHAT THE BILL.
THAT'S ISSUE RIGHT. SO THAT'S
ABOUT THE LEVEL. OF TWO.
AWARENESS NO OUR DISTRICT. YEAH
HE THOUGHT WITH SOMETHING WAS
DAYS ENOUGH. TO BE ABLE TO DO GO
OUT. TO PUT ME IN THE CAN. IN A
CERTAIN AREA THAT MIGHT MAKE A
BIT SO THOSE ARE THE THINGS THAT
I WOULD SAY THE BILL ISSUES.
FROM ALL ACROSS. WE DO IT ALL
TIME NO. LORD JURISDICTION. HAS
PRESCRIBED BY CPC. PEOPLE PUT
FORTH THE BILL WOULD WORK CALL
ONE COURTNEY AND COOPERATIVE
WITH THEIR FIVE DISTRICTS WITH
LOCAL CHURCH. HAVE THE ABILITY
THAT THE WAITED IT WE WILL WORK
WITH WITH THE THIS WORK AND IT
SHOULD BE GET NOTICE. M. WHAT
THAT NOTED AND WHAT THEY HAVE
CURRENTLY IN AND YOU DON'T IT'S
TOO MUCH TO ASK. NINETEEN SECOND
QUESTION AND WHICH MANY AND AT
WE THIS TO BE A STRONG BY. WHICH
TO MAKE YOU KNOW I AGAIN WANT TO
RETURN MY GRAD TO THE COMMITTEE
BECAUSE I THINK SOME THEIR ROOM
DINNER STATION IN I THINK MAY A
LOT OF SAN WE'RE TRY TO MAKE
THIS. IF THERE IS K. WILL. RIGHT
THAT BUT- IF. YEAH I THINK THIS
IS THE FIRST TIME WITH
ACCIDENTAL THAT THERE IS A
TRANSFORMER THAT EXPLODED I
WOULD JUST LIKE TO ALSO
HIGHLIGHT THAT IT EXPLODING
TRANSFORMERS NOT HARD WORK WE
PROVIDED DATA TO THE COMMITTEE
THAT. OUR TECHNICIANS ARE
RELATED TO PREFECTURE OR BADGE
MANAGE VEGETATION OR ANIMALS
COMING INTO CONTACT LINE IT'S
NOT HARD WORK SO TO BE CLEAR
AGAIN IF WE ARE HAPPY TO WORK ON
ANY STREAMLINED PROCESS TO SEE
IF THERE IS A- SPECIFIC ISSUE
REYES AND WITH REGARD TO- CIVIL
PENALTY- ANY FAR. STAR CHARISMA
LIABLE FOR ANY TALKS ABOUT SO WE
THINK THAT THAT'S THAT'S FAR
ABOVE AND BEYOND ARE CONCERNED
REAL OVER ANY SOAP AND- SO WE
HAVE THE SAME INTEREST IN
REDUCING FIRES. NOT QUITE. YEAH
JUST LOOKING AT A MAP HERE- I
HEARD THIS MORNING FROM A- IN
ANOTHER COMMITTEE OUR PURPOSE
WAS YESTERDAY THAT ABOUT HALF OF
THE GENIE'S CARE TORY AND I FIND
A RISK AREAS. ARE. YES LANDS IN
THEIR THE TO SAY THAT THIS IS
NOT A THING- I THE BILL DOESN'T
WORK I WOULD URGE MY FELLOW
COMMITTEE MEMBERS- TO TAKE.
PHOTO LATER ON WHEN THE BILL
COMES TO THE FLOOR BUT TO GIVE%
PEOPLE A CHANCE TO WORK THIS OUT
I DO THINK A VOLUNTARY AGREEMENT
WITH BURKE. I DON'T THINK THIS
IS GOING TO GO AWAY IT'S GOING
TO BE CERTAINLY A LOCAL
ORDINANCE EVEN IF IT DOES. THIS
IF THE FIGHT LOCAL FIRE CHIEFS
ONE THEY CAN EITHER GET LOCAL
ORDINANCE WHICH THEY CAN
PROBABLY GAP. THEN YOU KNOW I
DON'T SEE THAT THE BILL DOES ANY
HARM IF IT'S AMENDED THE WAY
HAVE SUGGESTED SO I AGAIN URGE
MY- FELLOW MEMBERS TO LET IT GO
TODAY AND THEY CAN DECIDE LETTER
WHEN IT COMES TO THE FLOOR.
THERE'S A NEED NOT TO VOTE FOR
THANK YOU. WE DO HAVE A MOTION
SECONDED BY ME BUT COURT. REYES
THE QUESTION A COMMON SUBJECT
CLOSE WITH ALL OF THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR EUROPE
THANK YOU EVERYONE. RENDON THE
CORPORATE WITH THE- WITH THE
NATION- QUESTION I REMEMBER
SEVEN AB TWENTY SEVENTY OF
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS EDUARDO GARCIA
WARDER CI PATTERSON. PATTERSON
NOT VOTING POWER QUE HAN HI
THERE CAN I CORREO. I CHEN.
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM NOT VOTING
CRISTINA GARCIA. HOLDEN HOLDEN
NUMBER EIGHTEEN. IRWIN MAYES
NUMBER MAYES NOT VOTING WERE
SEARCHING MASUCCI AYE CORK AYE
QUIRK AYE REYES. REYES I
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I TÍNH TING I. THAT'S THE THING IS LEAVE THE-
ROLE OPEN FOR THE MEMBERS TO ADD
ON. LAST WE'LL GO TO THE TOP.
AND THE MEMBERS THAT ARE PRESENT
- ADD ON. IT HAS WILL PLEASE.
SEVEN MEMBERS. SORRY. I JUST.
YEAH BY THE TOP. THE CONSENT
CONSENT FILE I NUMBER TWO I
REMEMBER FOR. ITEM EIGHT I
NUMBER NINE I DON'T TEN.
BARRICADE CAN THERE CAN I
CRISTINA GARCIA. HOLDEN HOLDEN I
WORK I WORK I REYES. REYES I
CHIANG SHANGHAI. THAT'S THIRTEEN
HOPEFULLY THEY'RE OPEN FOR A
COUPLE MORE NUMBERS TO COME BACK
IN THAT ON. SANTIAGO I'M SORRY.
CONSENT FILE SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I
. THAT'S FOURTEEN ZERO Q. FOR.
ITEM NUMBER ONE AB TWENTY TWO OH
FOUR THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS BAR CAN BEAR QUE
HAN I. HOLDEN HOLDEN I. SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO I CHIANG CHIANG I.
THAT'S THIRTEEN ONE. WAS THAT
YOU. WHO IS ASKING THE PAPER
REYES. FOR THE FRANCE I HAVE YOU
AS I ON AB TWENTY TWO OH FOUR.
OKAY THE ITEM NUMBER THREE AB
TWENTY SEVEN HUNDRED THE MOTION
IS DUE PASSED WITH THE AUTHORS
AGREEMENT TO TAKE AMENDMENTS AND
TRANSPORTATION. CAN I. HOLDEN
HOLDEN HI QUIRK I WORK I REYES
REYES I SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I
CHIANG CHING HI. THIRTEEN ZERO.
ONE OF THE FINAL TWO ACT. THE
ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB TWO EIGHT
EIGHT NINE THE MOTION IS DUE
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CRISTINA GARCIA. MAYES HI MAYES I. REYES REYES
I SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I CHING
CHING I. THIRTEEN ZERO. THE ITEM
NUMBER SIX AB TWENTY NINE THIRTY
SEVEN DO PASSED AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CUNNINGHAM
CUNNINGHAM I. QUIRK I QUIRK AYE
REYES REYES I SANTIAGO SANTIAGO
I THINK. TING I'D. YES ITEM
NUMBER ONE. IS AB TWENTY TWO OH
FOUR AND I HAVE YES I. YES MMHM
. I DON'T NUMBER SEVEN AB TWENTY
SEVENTY THE MOTION IS DUE PASSES
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS CHEN.
CRISTINA GARCIA IRWIN. IT'S
STILL EIGHT ZERO NOTHING OKAY. I
DON'T THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
THE MOBILE A PERFECT TOPIC OKAY. YEAH. FIFTY TWO ADULTS OVER
AND A THAT ARE. RECORDS SHOW
THAT I NEVER SAW. TAKE CARE OF
THAT FOR A VERYJOB IN THAT IT
WOULD AMENDMENT. BUT REALLY
CONVERTIBLE YEAH BILLS YOU TAKE
. WE'RE WE'RE- WHICH IS. THE
FORMER HE- YOUR- OKAY ACCORDING
TO. I FORGET THE MODEL. NINE
TUESDAY NIGHT OF. THERE WAS. TO
BUILD WAS THE ONE. WE APPRECIATE
GETTING THAT WHATEVER WOULD
HAPPEN TO GO TO THE- PROBLEM I
DON'T THINK WE'LL SEE THAT- YEAH
THE PEOPLE LIKE TO HAVE THAT TO
GET THE DEVELOPING FOR BRING
PROVIDE FRIEDMAN BILL FOR THE.
THE I HAVE TO WATCH WHAT THAT
YOU HAVE RIGHT. OKAY LET ME KNOW. A BIGGER PACKAGE WHAT CHANGE
BUT I'M SURE THING. GOT OKAY.
I DON'T NUMBER FIVE AB TWO EIGHT
EIGHT NINE THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
CRISTINA GARCIA CRISTINA GARCIA
I. THE BILL GETS OUT. WE'RE
GOING TO GO ALL THE WAY TO THE
TOP AGAIN. REUTERS M. AND
THROUGHOUT THE CONSENT FILE.
ITEM NUMBER TWO ITEM NUMBER FOR
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT NINE AND TEN.
THE VOTE HIS FOURTEEN ZERO BOTH
CLOSED IT OUT WHEN IT. CRISTINA
GARCIA ESTINA GARCIA HI NOW
THOSE BILLS GET OUT THIRTY. THE
pITEM NUMBER ONE AB TWENTY TWO OH
FOUR DO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS.
THAT BILL IS THIRTEEN ONE THIRD
AND ONE THE BILL COULD TELL.
ITEM NUMBER THIRTY. AB TWENTY
SEVEN HUNDRED DO PASSED WITH
AUTHORS AGREEMENT TO TAKE A
MOMENT AND TRANSPORTATION. FIVE
THIRTEEN ZERO THIRTEEN SO THAT
BILL THIS. ITEM NUMBER FIVE. TWO
EIGHT EIGHT NINE DO PASSED AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
FOURTEEN ZERO FOURTEEN ZERO THE
BILL GETS OUT. ITEM NUMBER SIX
AB TWO NINE THREE SEVEN DO
PASSED AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. BILLS FIFTEEN
ZERO FIFTEEN ZERO WITHOUT. ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN AB TWENTY SEVENTY
TWO PASSES AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CHEN CRISTINA
GARCIA ESTELA GARCIA I IRWIN.
NINE ZERO ANSWER BOOK IT UP.
THAT IS THE AGENDA FOR TODAY
APRIL TWENTIETH THE UTILITIES
AND ENERGY COMMITTEE WILL BE
TRACKED.